und es war der Beginn des größten
zivilbruchs die Erinnerung daran darf
niemals verblassen sie ist der Auftrag
dass sich so etwas niemals wiederholen
darf sie mahnt uns dass wir
Antisemitismus immer und mit aller Kraft
überall entgegentreten müssen
Antisemitismus ist aber jeder 1945
verschwunden noch ist er wie manche
behaupten erst durch Zuwanderung wieder
hierher gekommen nein er war immer da
und zwar nicht nur an den Rändern
sondern leider auch in unserer
Gesellschaft das zeigen uns Studien und
Erhebungen immer wieder sehr klar seit
Jahren verzeichnen wir einen
kontinuierlichen Anstieg antisemitischer
Straftaten oft sind es sogenannte
volksverhetzungsdelikte aber das aus
Worten Taten folgen können hat uns der
furchtbare Anschlag auf die Synagoge in
Halle sehr bitter vor Augen geführt und
ich will persönlich hinzufügen ich
schäme mich dafür dass in diesem Land
jüdische Kindertagesstätten und Schulen
noch immer polizeilich bewacht werden
müssen müssen alles dafür tun dass das
nicht mehr nötig ist meine Damen und
Herren
der antisemitische verschwörungswahn hat
während der corona-pandemie leider
Zulauf bekommen und antisemitische
Stereotype tauchen auch in vermeintlich
aufgeklärten Milieus immer wieder auf
das konnten wir gerade erst sehr bitter
auf der Dokumente in Kassel schmerzvoll
beobachten klar ist Antisemitismus
bedroht nicht allein Juden er bedroht
uns alle dieser Satz kann schnell wie
eine Plattitüde wirken aber er bringt es
auf den Punkt denn der Antisemitismus
ist ein Feind aller Jüdinnen und Juden
und zugleich der Feind aller
DemokratInnen und Demokraten in unserem
Land
die Bekämpfung von Antisemitismus muss
uns allen einen Anliegen sein denn
Antisemitismus ist niemals harmlos egal
ob er aus dem rechtsextremen dem
linksextremen oder dem islamistischen
Milieu stammt egal ob er an einem
Stammtisch oder in einer Moschee
verbreitet wird oder ob es sich um
israelfeindlichen Antisemitismus handelt
und hier möchte ich auch noch mal daran
gedenken weil es 50 Jahre her ist der
furchtbare Anschlag bei den Olympischen
Spielen 1972 den wir ja dieses Jahr auch
gedacht haben und ich denke dass das
ganz wichtig ist auch gerade dieses
herausragend schlimmer Ereignis für
Jüdinnen und Juden an einem solchen Tag
in Erinnerung zu rufen
wir werden deshalb
meine Damen und Herren nicht müde jede
Form von Antisemitismus entschlossen zu
bekämpfen dabei gehören an erster Stelle
die politische Bildung die
Präventionsarbeit die von klein auf
passieren muss und das entschlossene
Handeln unserer Sicherheitsbehörden
natürlich eng verzahnt zusammen alle
diese drei Maßnahmen müssen immer
ineinander greifen und das ist auch der
Kern unseres Aktionsplans gegen
Rechtsextremismus zusätzlich erarbeiten
wir gerade die erste nationale Strategie
zur Bekämpfung von Antisemitismus und
dem Schutz jüdischen Lebens in
Deutschland diese Strategie wird ein
Werkzeug sein um Antisemitismus noch
besser und zielgerichteter zu bekämpfen
glücklicherweise gibt es in Deutschland
eine starke und lebendige
Zivilgesellschaft die mit Engagement und
Beharrlichkeit
Antisemitismus Arbeit auch unterstützt
all den engagierten Menschen gilt dafür
mein ausdrücklicher Dank weil sie
leisten wirklich hervorragendes in der
Bekämpfung dieses furchtbaren
ja wirklich judenfeindlichen Handels-
und auch Hass und Hetze und diese
Menschen die das tun viele auch in ihrer
Freizeit und aber auch die NGOs die da
unterwegs sind müssen dafür auch eine
verlässliche Finanzierung und eine
verlässliche Unterstützung des Staates
haben und deshalb werden wir dieses Jahr
noch das demokratiefördergesetz auch auf
den Weg bringen meine Damen und Herren
heute geht es zuallererst darum dass wir
den Millionen Opfern gedenken die uns
und ihrer erinnern und doch hört man
immer wieder das sei doch gar nicht mehr
nötig bei einem Drittel der Bevölkerung
ist das in Umfragen der Fall und das
erschüttert mich sehr und muss uns
wachrütteln dass wir was für das aktive
erinnern auch tun müssen
wer so argumentiert meine Damen und
Herren hat den Sinn und Zweck von
erinnern nämlich nicht verstanden es
geht darum so hat das Josef Schuster der
Vorsitzende des Zentralrats der Juden
gesagt dass auch die nachfolgenden
Generationen lernen wozu Menschen fähig
sind sie sollen verstehen warum in
unserem Staat die Achtung der
Menschenwürde und der Schutz von
Minderheiten so wichtig genommen werden
und meine Damen und Herren das darf ich
auch sagen wer in diesem Zusammenhang
von einem Vogelschiss oder einer
auschwitz-keule spricht verhöhnt die
Opfer der Shoa und das werden wir in
diesem Land nicht zulassen meine Damen
und Herren
wir werden nie vergessen und wir werden
alles tun damit das was so furchtbar in
diesem Land sich durch Menschen Ereignis
hat durch Menschen die das bewusst getan
haben dass so etwas nie wieder in
unserem Land passieren kann und dazu
gehört aktives Handeln des Rechtsstaates
aber auch eine herausragende
Erinnerungskultur vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer hat
hier die Debatte eröffnet aufgrund des
besonderen Datums aber auch aufgrund
natürlich der
Handlungsnotwendigkeit die wir
angesichts der Zahlen haben unter die
Bedeutung sehen wir auch an der
Regierungsbank die fast vollständig ist
an diesem Tag Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
verehrte Gäste auf der Tribüne
die Erinnerung darf nicht enden unter
diesem Titel veranstalten eine
Bürgerinitiative und die jüdische
Gemeinde in meinem Wahlkreis in
Recklinghausen in diesem Minuten ein
gedenkonzert und eine Gedenkstunde in
der örtlichen Synagoge
es wird nicht die einzige Veranstaltung
hier in unserem Land heute sein
auch wenn ich nicht dabei sein kann die
Erinnerung darf nicht enden das ist an
dieser Stelle die Losung die wir heute
in dieser Debatte erneuern und den
Menschen zu rufen sollten das gilt
gerade wenn wir heute an die in der
Nacht vom 9 auf den 10 November 1938 von
SA und SS organisierten prognome
erinnern wir erinnern diese schreckliche
Nacht und an all das was auf sie folgte
aber in dem Titel unserer Debatte heute
hier im Deutschen Bundestag verbirgt
sich ein wichtiger Satz
erinnern heißt handeln und Handeln ist
wichtig denn es geht schlicht darum dass
jeder gleich Welle der Religion in
unserem Land sicher und frei leben darf
und das ist unser Auftrag
[Applaus]
und der Vizepräsident des jüdischen
Weltkongresses mal am Stern hat im
Vorfeld wie ich finde zu Recht darauf
hingewiesen dass wir nicht glauben
sollten dass gedenkdebatten so nützlich
und wichtig sie auch sind schon
ausreichend um uns vor zukünftige
Katastrophen zu bewahren allein ganz
sicher nicht blicken wir aktuell auf den
Antisemitismus in unserem Land dann gibt
es nichts schön zu reden er ist in der
Gesellschaft offener denn je präsent
Studien der Polizei in Umfragen zeigen
antisemitische Vorurteile Stereotype
kollektive Schuldzuweisung und
verschwörungsmythen sind leider fast
alltäglich
und ja deswegen braucht es übrigens auch
einen starken Verfassungsschutz
ein Amt an dem sich gut ablesen lässt
wie wichtig es ist weil sich die
Extremisten von allen Seiten so sehr
daran abarbeiten und wie wichtig es auch
ist nicht nur zu reden sondern als
Demokratie auch zu handeln schlicht
wehrhaft zu sein egal wo in unserem Land
es ist inakzeptabel dass sich jüdische
Menschen oft nicht mehr trauen ihre
Religion zu praktizieren und zu zeigen
das wirft einen Schatten auf unser
Gemeinwesen auf unsere freiheitlich hier
Demokratie denn ein Angriff auf
jüdisches Leben und das muss heute klar
sein ist immer auch ein Angriff auf uns
alle
ich begrüße daher dass die
Innenministerkonferenz auf ihrer Tagung
im Sommer den dringenden Handlungsbedarf
bei der Prävention von antisemitischer
und anti-israelischer Hitze erkannt hat
am 30.11 treffen sich die Innenminister
erneut
und ich bin mir sicher es wird konkrete
Ansätze für eine notwendige
Weiterentwicklung von Maßnahmen geben
und diese werden auch beschlossen
aber wenn wir den Blick auf dieses Jahr
werfen so gehört in dieser Debatte auch
die Frage dazu wie es möglich sein
konnte dass die öffentlich geförderte
dokumenter fifty in Kassel zu einer der
schwersten Fälle von Antisemitismus in
den letzten Jahren mutieren konnte dass
dort judenfeindliche Kunstwerke offen
gezeigt wurden ist durch nichts zu
entschuldigen und es wäre heute eine
gute Gelegenheit wenn wir
fraktionsübergreifend als konsequent zu
diesen Vorkommnissen und einig darüber
zeigen dass es eine grundsätzliche
förderklausel des bundesbedarf die
vorsieht keine Veranstaltung mehr mit
Steuermitteln zu finanzieren die
Antisemitismus propagieren es sollte
eigentlich eine Selbstverständlichkeit
und natürlich
haben wir in den letzten Jahren in
meinem Kampf gegen den
antisemitismus-parteiübergreifend gerade
auch bei der Schaffung von Strukturen
viel Gutes erreicht ich nenne eine neu
aufgestellte Antisemitismusforschung die
Einrichtung einer und länderkommission
sowie das Amt des Antisemitismus
Beauftragten der Bundesregierung und ich
möchte in diesem Zusammenhang heute
ausdrücklich dem Antisemitismus
Beauftragten der Bundesregierung dr
Felix Klein für sein großes und
wichtiges Engagement ausdrücklich Dank
an herzlichen Dank Weitergeben der
Bericht heute im Innenausschuss er war
sehr eindrucksvoll
und wir brauchen
wenn wir es ernst meinen in der Zukunft
den 360 Grad Blick neben dem
Rechtsextremismus stellt das von
Islamisten verbreitete antisemitische
Gedankengut eine wachsende Gefahr für
das friedliche und tolerante
Zusammenleben in der Bundesrepublik da
auch im linken Spektrum
hat Antisemitismus Zulauf etwa im Zuge
von Kapitalismuskritik Antizionismus und
Antiimperialismus es ist auch eine
Schande wie viel antisemitische Hetze
Menschenverachtung und Verharmlosung des
Völkermordes an den europäischen Juden
auch von corona-leugnern und
Verschwörungstheoretikern verbreitet
wird das dürfen wir als Rechtsstaat
nicht dulden
und dies alles dies alles geschieht auch
immer mehr im Internet es ist
inakzeptabel wenn Betreiber sozialer
Netzwerke ihrer Pflicht nicht nachkommen
antisemitische Hassbotschaften innerhalb
der vorgesehenen Fristen die vorgegeben
sind zu löschen die Plattform das muss
ein Appell sein müssen hier konsequenter
vorgehen und ihrer unternehmerischen
Verantwortung gerecht werden
gleichzeitig müssen wir aber auch an
neuen Wegen arbeiten um anonyme Hetze im
Netz besser zu identifizieren
daneben sind auch
länderübergreifende Konzepte
Justizbereich erforderlich die Bewertung
als antisemitisch motivierte Straftat
die verlangt umfassende Kenntnis der
Tatumstände um den Kontext jeder
einzelnen Tat richtig beurteilen zu
können müssen außerdem im
Schulterschluss und das tun wir auch mit
den europäischen Partnern agieren mit
der im Oktober 2021 vorgelegten
Strategie zu Bekämpfung von
Antisemitismus und zu Förderung
jüdischen Lebens verpflichtet sich die
EU-Kommission dazu jüdisches Leben in
Europa und auch weltweit künftig zu
fördern meine Fraktion begrüßt diese
Strategie ausdrücklich aber auch der
Sport spielt eine große Rolle
im Kampf gegen Antisemitismus und
rechtsextremen Gedankengut trägt
insbesondere der Fußball eine
Riesenverantwortung und da war es ein
gutes Zeichen das für die Verdienste zum
Beispiel des Fußball-Bundesligisten
Borussia Dortmund im Kampf gegen den
Antisemitismus vor wenigen Tagen
Funktionäre des BVB ausgezeichnet wurden
was die wenigsten vielleicht wissen
wir müssen auch positiv vorangehen und
jüdisches Leben positiv in den
Vordergrund stellen und fördern und in
diesem Sinne sehe ich mit großem
Optimismus
insbesondere auch auf die jüngere
Generation
ich erlebe dort oft Offenheit Neugier
ehrliches Interesse das macht mir das
kann uns allen Hoffnung machen vielen
herzlichen Dank
die Rede des Bericht erstattet
für Antisemitismus der Unionsfraktion
und wir sehen mittlerweile sind alle
Ministerinnen und Minister in dieser
Debatte anwesend und hören nun Lamia zu
der Sprecherin für Innen- und
Religionspolitik der 9 November ist für
uns Deutsche ein sehr wichtiges Datum
und ich bin daher sehr froh dass wir
heute diese Debatte zum Antisemitismus
hier im Plenum gemeinsam führen denn wir
erinnern an das antisemitische Grauen in
unserem Land vor 84 Jahren wurden über
1.200 Synagogen niedergebrannt unzählige
Wohnungen verwüstet und etwa 7.500
jüdische Geschäfte zerstört Jüdinnen und
Juden wurden erschlagen niedergestochen
oder zu Tode gepökelt kurz darauf wurde
im ganzen deutschen Reich über 30.000
Männer verhaftet und in die
Konzentrationslager Sachsenhausen Dachau
und Buchenwald deportiert
alles Geschichte mitnichten auch 84
Jahre später müssen wir ausgerechnet in
Deutschland und es ist absolut
beschämend noch immer über Hass und
Hetze gegen Juden und Juden sprechen
sehr geehrte sehr geehrter Herr
Präsident meine Damen und Herren ich
möchte Ihnen von einer Begegnung
berichten meine muslimischen Kinder
besuchen beide den jüdischen
Kindergarten in Duisburg dieser liegt
aus Sicherheitsgründen am Ende eines
Innenhofs mit einer Pforte aus
Panzerglas hinter der ein
Sicherheitsmann sitzt und den
Sicherheitszaun samt Grundstück bewacht
ich wollte eines unserer Kinder an einem
Nachmittag ab und begleitete es Hand in
Hand aus dem Kindergarten plötzlich rief
ein älterer Mann von oben von seinem
Balkon euch hätte man alle vergasen
müssen
ich legte mich lautstark mit ihm an und
versuchte an meinem erschrockenen Kind
zu erklären dass der Herr voller
Abneigung wäre es aber nicht an uns
liege ich gebe zu dass ich nach dem
Schlagabtausch still aber aufgewühlt von
mir her dachte was hätte er gedacht wenn
er gewusst hätte dass ich Muslimen und
nicht Jüdin bin
Wut und Frustration erfüllten mich diese
Szene die ich nicht vergessen kann zeigt
dass Antisemitismus keine Jüdinnen und
Juden benötigt um zu funktionieren es
kann jede und jeden treffen jedes Mal
wenn eine Jüdin oder ein Jude
angegriffen wird ist es als würden wir
selbst angegriffen und so sehe ich es
Menschenfeindlichkeit macht nämlich von
niemanden halt am Ende trifft es die
Demokratie als Ganzes es ist daher
inakzeptabel das Jüdinnen und Juden im
Jahr 2022 in Deutschland Angst haben
müssen in der Öffentlichkeit religiöse
Symbole zu tragen die Schule zu besuchen
oder in einer jüdische Kultureinrichtung
zu gehen
insbesondere seit Beginn der
corona-pandemie verzeichnen wir eine
Ausbreitung des Antisemitismus durch
impfgegnerinnen und Impfgegner
sogenannten spaziergänger:innen
querdenker:innen flaktiert von den
altbekannten rechtsextremistischen
islamistischen und auch
linksextremistischen Strömungen mit
ihren antisemitischen Denkmustern und
Verschwörungsideologien wird der Hass in
der Mitte in die Mitte der Gesellschaft
gespült die steigenden Zahlen zur
politisch motivierten Kriminalität und
die Hasskriminalität gegen Jüdinnen und
Juden die auch in der digitalen Realität
tobt unterstreichen den Handlungsbedarf
Bekämpfung von Antisemitismus ist
Kernaufgabe einer Bundesregierung die
ihre Bürgerinnen und Bürger schützt die
den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt und
die Resilienz der Demokratie stärkt und
Sicherheit gewährleistet
wir verzeichnen zwar Erfolge bei der
Sichtbarmachung jüdischen Lebens und
beim empowerment jüdischer Gemeinden in
Deutschland das heißt aber nicht dass
nicht noch viel zu tun wäre um jüdisches
Leben weiter zu stärken ist die
Errichtung einer Stelle zu Erforschung
jüdischer Lebensrealitäten ein wichtiger
Schritt und daher werden wir einen
nationale Strategie zu bekämpfen von
Antisemitismus vorliegen deren
Notwendigkeit auch heute dr klein im
Innenausschuss betont hatte bei der
Prävention müssen wir schon früh
anfangen Lehrinhalte und Exkursionen mit
sehr guter Vor- und Nachbereitung müssen
aus meiner Sicht verpflichtend werden
Pädagogen und Pädagogen Erzieherinnen
und Erzieher müssen besser geschult
werden wer Diskriminierungen unserer
Gesellschaft verkämmt wer bei Protesten
jeglicher Couleur mitmarschiert und
dabei antisemitischen Bekundungen duldet
ist eine Gefahr für unser Land und
dieser Gefahr müssen und werden sich die
demokratischen Fraktionen in diesem Haus
gemeinsam entgegenstellen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kolleginnen
das nächste Wort die Kollegin Beatrix
von Storch afd-fraktion
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
wer im Jahr 22 über Antisemitismus redet
kann von der gefährlichsten
antisemitischen Bewegung in Westeuropa
nicht schweigen der bds-bewegung die hat
eine schüsselfunktion sie ist das
dreckige Bindeglied zwischen dem linken
und muslimischen Antisemitismus von
Intellektuellen Künstlern Aktivisten von
Greta Thunberg und Claudia Roth zum
gewaltbereiten muslimischen
Antisemitismus von isbollah und Hamas
der Titel dieser Aussprache heißt
erinnern und handeln also erinnern wir
uns der Bundestag hat eine Resolution
zur BDS verabschiedet und eine gegen
Antisemitismus alles ohne jede messbare
Wirkung die
antisemitismus-resolution fordert
ausländerrechtliche Konsequenzen also
Abschiebung bei Antisemitismus das ist
nicht ein einziges Mal passiert und die
BDS Resolution sagt dass die
bds-bewegung keine Räume mehr bekommt
und keine finanziellen Mittel das lehnt
kulturstaatsministerin Roth in ihrer
abstimmungserklärung vom 17 mai 2019
expressis verbis ab solange sich
Deutschland also eine solche
kulturstaatsministerin leistet ist der
Kampf gegen Antisemitismus eine fast
bestenfalls eine Phase eigentlich eher
eine Verhöhnung der Opfer kommen wir zum
Handeln
wenn man etwas gegen den Judenhass
erreichen will sollte man sich das Land
angucken das als einziges in dem sich
die Juden als einziges seit Merkels
flüchtlingskrise 2015 sicherer fühlen
weniger angegriffen fühlen als
vormerkels flüchtlingskrise und das ist
Ungarn die Europäische Union hat in
ihrer zweiten großen Erhebung 2018
16.000 Juden in Westeuropa befragt das
Ergebnis ist eindeutig der Anteil der
Juden die zum Beispiel Angst vor
gewaltsamen Angriffen haben wo denn
Ungarn zwischen 2012 und 2018 auf unter
30 Prozent halbiert in Deutschland ist
im selben Zeitraum diese Quote auf über
60 Prozent gestiegen Angst bei Juden vor
Übergriffen über 60% nach einer Erhebung
der Europäischen Union der Anteil der
Juden die tatsächlich
Opfer von Übergriffen wurden ist in
Ungarn 17 Prozent zurückgegangen und in
Deutschland um etwa ein Drittel auf
knapp 30 Prozent gestiegen knapp 30
Prozent aller Juden in Deutschland
Opfer von Angriffen Rabbiner Slomo Köbis
sagte das Gute Beispiel Ungarn sollte
man auf die ganze EU anwenden Merkels
bundland ist für Juden immer
gefährlicher und Orbans dezidiert
katholisches Ungarn ist für Jugend immer
sicherer oder wie im Dezember 2017 die
linksliberale israelische Zeitung Haras
titelte ich zitiere
wörtliches keeping juice safe bei
keeping Muslims out Zitat Ende
und statt Hans-Georg Maaßen zu
verleumden sollten sich unsere Lima
unsere linken klima-terroristen um Luisa
Neubauer dem Antisemitismus in ihrer
klimasektor widmen von Hamburg bis nach
Gaza Klima in tifada das war der
Schlachtruf mehr muss man gar nicht
wissen diese grünen Klima Spinner sind
ideologisch verloren extremistisch und
auch antisemitisch wir sollten die alle
irgendwo hinkleben an irgendeinen hohlen
Baumstumpf wo sie niemanden stören und
keinen mehr töten können erinnern und
Handeln steht über dieser Debatte heute
sie sind hier in der Regierung und
könnten handeln aber sie werden wieder
nichts tun wenn die AFD regiert werden
wir Judenhasser und Islamisten
abschieben und keine neuen mehr
hereinlassen werden
haschmuseen schließen BDS Bewegung
verbieten die auslandsfinanzierung von
Moscheen unterbinden und wo die AFD
regiert wird der mulzinruf in unseren
Städten verstummen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
nicht so Rednerin ist die Kollegin
hinter Torte Weg FDP-Fraktion
herr Präsident sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren und die ganze Straße sah zu so
schilderte Joseph Schuster heute bei
einer Gedenkveranstaltung auf Einladung
des Bundespräsidenten Gedanken von
deutschen Staatsbürgern jüdischen
Glaubens die die reichspo diese
programmnacht erlebt haben diese Tage
der Ermordung Erniedrigung von Menschen
in unserem Land was uns mit Scham und
Trauer erfüllen muss und es ist ein
großes Geschenk für unser Land und
Ausdruck eines großen
vertrauensvorschusses das wieder
Jüdinnen und Juden in unserem Land leben
und uns am Land diesen
Vertrauensvorschuss gegeben haben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
umso
umso beschämender ist es denn erinnern
heißt handeln und da geht es auch um die
Sicherheit von Jüdinnen und Juden heute
in unserem Land das verschiedene Akteure
heute sich nicht verkneifen können
diesen historischen Tag zu benutzen für
andere politische Anliegen ich will
jetzt nicht über die Kundgebungen die es
auch heute abend leider in Berlin geben
wird
an denen wahrscheinlich wieder auch
Israel bezogene Antisemitismus Ausdruck
findet stattfinden sondern nur
beispielhaft etwas anderes herausgreifen
was ich mir nach dem
dokumenta-skandal der einer mit Ansage
und Wegbereitern war nicht hätte
vorstellen können dass das
Goethe-Institut in Tel Aviv zum Beispiel
vorhatte am heutigen Tag ernsthaft
gemeinsam mit der
Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung eine
Veranstaltung unter dem Motto den
Schmerz der anderen verstehen über die
Nachbar zu veranstalten gefördert mit
öffentlichen Geldern das zeigt wie prüft
das Problem sitzt und wie ernsthaft wir
uns damit auseinandersetzen müssen
Liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Antisemitismus kein neues Thema ist dass
er ein beschämender Teil des Alltags in
unserem Land ist das ist für uns frei
Demokraten nicht neu und es ist nicht
überraschend allein ist tröstet nicht
das beruhigt nicht denn es geht um eine
gemeinsame große Verantwortung für ein
hohes Gut nämlich dafür dass jüdisches
Leben bei uns sicher frei und
selbstbestimmt stattfinden kann und vor
allem das Jüdinnen und Juden selbst
darauf vertrauen und da darf es nicht
von der Stärke einer synagogentür
abhängen wie in Halle ob Jüdinnen und
Juden sich sicher fühlen können
und der notwendige Polizeischutz der
eben schon erwähnt wurde der ist ebenso
notwendig wie es traurig ist dass er
notwendig ist und deshalb ist es nicht
hinreichend dass wir ihn gewährleisten
wir müssen die gesellschaftlichen Türen
vor Antisemitismus fest verschließen vor
menschenverachtenden Gedankengut damit
es oft realen Türen nicht ankommt
auffällig am Antisemitismus ist dass er
regelmäßig Hand in Hand mit
verschwörungserzählungen geht und dass
er uns auch in verschiedenen Debatten
außenpolitischen wirtschaftspolitischen
und kulturpolitischen begegnet ist ein
hilfloser Reflex auf die Komplexität
moderner Gesellschaften und ihrer
Herausforderungen und es gilt diesen
menschenverachtenden Gedankengut immer
und überall klar entgegenzutreten egal
ob es auch vermeintlich geschmeidig
gefällig harmlos entgegenkommt denn klar
ist jeder Erscheinungsform von
Antisemitismus ist inakzeptabel
und
weil die Erinnerungskultur die wir uns
in unserem Land erarbeitet haben nämlich
was in liberalen Demokratien übrigens
gerade nicht die Normalität sondern
etwas sehr Besonderes und kostbares ist
dass man nämlich eine historische
Tatsache auch moralisch eindeutig
bewertet und nicht verschiedene
Meinungen darüber hat sondern ein klaren
Konsens darüber über die Singularität
des menschheitsverbrechens der Shoa
gerade deshalb muss es uns besorgen dass
es neue Tendenzen der Relativierung und
der Verharmlosung gibt
die weil diese Erinnerungskultur so
kostbar ist und weil sich die
Erinnerungskultur weiterentwickeln muss
mit unserer Gesellschaft ohne diese
Verantwortung zu verlieren müssen uns
Apartheid zum Kolonialismus
Analogien auch besorgen denn es darf
nicht zu einer Verharmlosung kommen
nicht zu einer Relativierung
denn dort sind regelmäßig
Doppelstandards Dämonisierung und
Delegitimierung des Staates Israel nicht
weit die Showa ist singulär ihre
Dimension sie ist schwerlich in Sprache
zu fassen und doch müssen wir sie
benennen weil wir sie nicht beschweigen
dürfen
der glaubt die Glaubwürdigkeit des
Kampfes gegen Antisemitismus die hängt
davon ab das ist kein Unterschied macht
aus welcher Ecke Antisemitismus kommt
wir brauchen eine ganzheitliche
Strategie gegen Antisemitismus über die
werden wir aber in den nächsten Wochen
auch ausführlicher sprechen können und
deshalb denke ich geht es jetzt darum
dass wir in eine Situation kommen in der
mehr Raum ist als es heute war denn
heute beschäftigt und belastet uns denke
ich eher der starke der unerträglich
starke Antisemitismus dass wir auch über
die Vielfalt jüdischen Lebens und die
Vielfalt jüdischer Kultur in unserem
Land sprechen können ich finde das wäre
ein gutes Ziel für zukünftige Debatten
dass man seine Redezeit darauf verwenden
kann auf diese Vielfalt jüdischer Kultur
und jüdischen Lebens in Deutschland
vielen Dank
lindert heute Berg sagt das jüdisches
Leben frei und sicher stattfinden soll
wenn man sich aber zum Beispiel den
Jahresbericht des Bundesverbands der
Recherche und Informationsstellen
Antisemitismus RIAS anschaut dann findet
das eben nicht statt
2738 strafbare und nicht strafbare
Vorfälle wurden gemeldet
der Präsident sehr geehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen sehr geehrte Gäste es war
und bleibt richtig dass wir im Bundestag
an den 9 November
1938 die Reichspogromnacht erinnern
danach beschlossen die Nazis den
systematischen Mord an allen Jüdinnen
und Juden und es folgte ein unsägliches
Menschheitsverbrechen
deshalb sage ich auch wer diese
furchtbare Zeit und diese Vorgänge als
Vogelschiss deutscher Geschichte
verharmlost macht sich nachträglich mit
der nötige Rückblick ersetzt aber nicht
den aktuellen draufblick und die
pünktliche Debatte im Bundestag darf
nicht das alltägliche Dilemma ausblenden
Antisemitismus ist präsent und bedroht
Jüdinnen und Juden hierzulande weil sie
Jüdinnen und Juden sind das ist wieder
den Anspruch des Grundgesetzes aber es
ist vor allen Dingen auch eine Gefahr
für Leib und Leben und deshalb nicht
hinnehmbar
einmal im Quartal frage ich die
Bundesregierung wie viele Straf- und
Gewalttaten sie mit antisemitischen
Hintergrund registriert hat die Zahlen
sind hoch und steigend das ist schlimm
zugleich stapeln Sie tief denn
Antisemitismus erfahren Jüdinnen und
Juden auch im Alltag viele Wagen es
bereits nicht mehr sich öffentlich
jüdisch zu bekennen und deshalb reicht
es nicht an 1938 und die Nazizeit zu
erinnern der Bundestag die Politik die
Gesellschaft müssen sich verstärkt gegen
aktuellen Antisemitismus engagieren
das kontra zum Antisemitismus bedarf
aber eines pro zum jüdischen Leben
und das beginnt in der Schulzeit
Schülerinnen und Schüler erfahren als zu
oft im Unterricht erstmals etwas über
Juden wenn es um den Holocaust geht
danach sind Juden dann vor allen Dingen
Opfer über jüdische Kultur jüdisches
Leben in der Geschichte und in unserer
Gesellschaft erfahren sie kaum etwas und
das muss ich dringend ändern dem
Nobelpreisträger die Künstlerinnen und
Künstler die erfolgreichen Sportler
überhaupt Jüdinnen und Juden gehören in
die Lehrpläne und in das alltägliche
Leben
und auch ein aktuelles Thema natürlich
sind die christlichen Feiertage aus
unserem Jahreskalender nicht wegzudenken
was ist eigentlich mit jüdischen
Feiertagen oder wenigstens dem Respekt
vor der Religionsausübung sei es bei der
Terminierung von Prüfung oder bei der
Organisation in den Hochschulen oder im
Arbeitsleben auch hier ist noch viel
Handel
ein letzter Punkt es wurde schon erwähnt
wir haben heute Vormittag im
Innenausschuss mit dem Beauftragten für
jüdisches Leben und zur Bekämpfung des
Antisemitismus über die im Moment in
Entwicklung befindliche nationale
Strategie zur Bekämpfung des
Antisemitismus gesprochen ich hoffe sehr
die Bundesregierung ist ja hier nahezu
vollständig vertreten dass sie Ende des
Monats diese Strategie entsprechend
verabschieden und dass wir uns gemeinsam
der Umsetzung derselben und der
Verbreitung bis in die letzte Kommune
annehmen und uns entsprechend engagieren
ich danke Ihnen
besonders
von der Wunsch von Petra Pau kam der
Krise ist der nächste Redner
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident Kolleginnen
und Kollegen sehr geehrter Herr
Botschafter der heutigen 9 November ist
kein normaler Tag es ist ein Tag zum
Innehalten zum Erinnern an dem wir den
Blick in die Vergangenheit richten
müssen denn der 9 November wird zu Recht
als Schicksalstag der deutschen
bezeichnet an diesem Tag nahmen viele
Schicksale in diesem Land in den letzten
Jahrzehnten eine unerwartete
hoffnungsvolle aber auch grausame
Wendung ein am 9 November 1989 haben
viele in der ehemaligen DDR neue
Hoffnung geschöpft auf eine Zukunft mit
mehr Freiheit und mehr Möglichkeiten für
sich und ihre Familien und es war ein
guter Tag für unser heute wieder
vereinigtes Land der 9 November 1938 war
aber das genaue Gegenteil in
nationalsozialistischen Deutschland
kommt es zu organisierten Übergriffen
gegen Jüdinnen und Juden jüdische Läden
Institutionen werden zerstört Synagogen
brennen werden verwüstet bei mir im
Sauerland unter anderem in Arnsberg
Meschede und Brilon Polizei und
Feuerwehr hatten damals die Weisung
nicht einzugreifen wollten es oftmals
auch gar nicht Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
Nachbarn machten aktiv mit oder schauten
Weg in dieser Nacht haben jüdische
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger vielleicht
endgültig erkannt dieser Terrorstaat hat
sich gegen sie entschieden er hat über
ihr Schicksal befunden und es für nicht
schützenswert ja nicht lebenswert
erachtet und dieser Hass gegen unsere
jüdischen Mitbürger mündete in dem
schrecklichsten Zivilisationsbruch
unserer Geschichte die
Menschheitsverbrechen der Showa und ich
sage ganz deutlich für unsere
Verantwortung vor der Geschichte gibt es
keinen Schlussstrich der 9 November ist
hier für Mahnung und Warnung an uns alle
zugleich
der Kampf gegen Antisemitismus und die
Förderung jüdischen Lebens ist unsere
gemeinsame Aufgabe und die Aufgabe aller
Demokraten hier im Haus denn das
vergangene Jahr hat es uns doch gezeigt
jüdisches Leben gehört seit 1700 Jahren
zu unserem Land zu unserer Geschichte
und es ist ein Teil von uns und gerade
deshalb sind wir alle verpflichtet gegen
Judenhass und Judenfeindschaft
aufzustehen und zu handeln das ist die
Lehre die wir aus der Geschichte ziehen
müssen und gerade die jüngere Generation
steht hier in der Verantwortung gerade
in einer Zeit wo wir uns die Frage
stellen müssen wie Erinnerungskultur
zukünftig möglich ist wenn die
Zeitzeugen nicht mehr unter uns sind und
Kolleginnen und Kollegen erheben wir
deshalb gemeinsam unsere Stimme gegen
jede Form des Antisemitismus egal in
welchem Gewand er daherkommt und egal
wie er sich in der Neuzeit ausbreitet
sei es mit verschwörungstheoretischen
Vorurteilen während der Finanzkrise
während der corona-pandemie wo es
abscheulichste Vergleiche gerade mit
Anne Frank gegeben hat gerade in diese
Zeiten wo hast und Hetze einer lauten
Minderheit zuzunehmen scheiden gerade in
diesen Zeiten sind wir gemeinsam
gefordert klären wir darum auf wo
verschwörungserzählungen und
Diffamierung jüdische Menschen treffen
stehen wir gemeinsam auf und geben wir
dem Antisemitismus in der Mitte unsere
Gesellschaft keinen Platz vielen Dank
[Applaus]
wie auch andere schon zuvor auch den
Botschafter des Staates Israel hier
besonders gegrüßt Ron Poser schaut hier
auch zu genauso wie der Vizepräsident
des Zentralrats der Juden Marke einbauen
Kollegen es ist eine gute Entscheidung
gewesen dass wir im heutigen Tage hier
im Hohen Hause
der Frage nachgehen was wir gegen
Antisemitismus in Deutschland tun können
der Vorsitzende der Zentralrats der
Juden in Deutschland hat ein klein wenig
gemahnt und hat gesagt der 9 November
ist in der deutschen Geschichte eben mit
vielen Facetten versehen ich glaube die
die mich am meisten zum Nachdenken
bringen ist eben doch das Datum des 9
November 1938 weil das was dort
geschehen ist was in der folgegeschehen
ist eine so unbeschreibliche
Zivilisationsbruch gewesen ist dass man
als junger und auch als erwachsener
Mensch immer noch damit zu kämpfen hat
dass wirklich zu verstehen und
nachzuvollziehen wir denken an die
vielen Opfer aber wir denken auch an
diejenigen die sich in der Folge des 9
November 38
schuldig gemacht haben entweder weil sie
weggesehen haben weil sie verweigert
haben die Hilfe gegenüber jüdischen
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürgern die von
der SA und vom Mob verprügelt worden
sind die deportiert und umgebracht
worden sind und die sich bereichert
haben an dem Vermögen ihre jüdischen
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger und die zum
Teil bis weit in die Nachkriegszeit zu
ihrem Tode nicht verstanden haben dass
das Unrecht war sich zu bereichern an
dem an dem Vermögen dass den Juden
weggenommen worden war und das ist auch
ein Thema an dass ich heute denke ich
komme aus einem
Wahlkreis in dem es eine gebärgische
Land Sodingen Remscheid Wuppertal in dem
es eine starke jüdische Gemeinde gibt
die ist in den 90er Jahren deutlich
gewachsen als auch als Ergebnis des
Falls das Eisernen Vorhangs und es hat
dann in meiner Heimatstadt Wuppertal
eine Ereignis gegeben an dem der heutige
Botschafter des Staates Israel in
Deutschland von Brose auch persönlichen
Anteil hatte es wurde in Wuppertal eine
neue Synagoge gebaut und zwar auf dem
Grunde Boden den die evangelische Kirche
die gemarkerkirche in Wuppertal dort wo
die Barmer Synode getagt hat die das
letzte Aufbäumen der Christen gegen den
Nationalsozialismus 1935 oder eines der
großen letzten aufbäumung diese
Kirchengemeinde hat für einen
symbolischen Markt der jüdischen
Gemeinde ein Grundstück verkauft und ist
die neue Synagoge dort errichtet worden
und ronproso hat damals als junger
Diplomat daran maßgeblichen Anteil
gehabt dass die dann von den Präsidenten
kazav und rau Wuppertaler Bürger
eingeweiht wurde ich erinnere aber auch
daran dass im Jahr 2014
drei junge Menschen Jugendliche
breinbrandanschlag versucht haben zu
verüben auf diese Synagoge gott sei Dank
ist der Brandsatz nicht gezündet aber
wenn er gezündet wäre wäre diese
Synagoge erheblich beschädigt oder gar
ein Brand geraten worden und dann gab es
ein Gerichtsurteil und dann haben die
jungen Menschen in diesem kriegsurteil
gesagt sie wollten mit ihrer Aktion ja
nur gegen die israelische Politik gegen
die Palästinenser demonstrieren
bemerke den Fehler der Angriff auf ein
jüdisches Gotteshaus in Deutschland wird
gerechtfertigt mit einem Protest gegen
israelische Politik und es hat die
Richter zu einem vergleichsweise milden
Strafmaß verleitet und das hat weltweit
international aufzählen erregt und bis
heute zu wirkt das in der jüdischen
Gemeinde in Wuppertal nach wir hatten
dann 192021 die Situation dass unsere
Freunde aus der Patenstadt von Solingen
nesciona in der Stadt waren es war die
fahndete Staates Israel vor dem Rathaus
in Solingen gehisst auch über Nacht und
dann wurde diese Fahne in der Nacht
1921/21 im Frühsommer in Brand gesetzt
wir haben daraus den Schluss gezogen
dass wir einmal im Jahr nämlich immer
dann wenn unsere Freunde aus nestione an
Solingen da sind einen Tag machen an dem
wir das jüdische Leben in Solingen
sichtbar machen indem wir uns vor dem
Rathaus versammeln eine Kipper tragen
und damit zeigen dass man als Mensch in
Deutschland jüdischen Glaubens den
Schutz aller anderen verdient und
genießt wenn man sich zu seinem Glauben
bekennt und seinen Glauben ausübt aber
das ist nach wie vor in Deutschland
passiert das israelische Fahnen
angezündet werden ist ein erschreckendes
Zeichen und mahnt uns weiter aktiv gegen
Antisemitismus zu kämpfen
zum Schluss möchte ich noch einen Satz
sagen vielleicht auch als Vizepräsident
der Deutsche ist göttlichen Gesellschaft
was wir vielleicht auch noch tun können
um das Verständnis der Deutschen für die
Politik und für das Leben in Israel zu
verbessern ich glaube dass wir noch
viele Wege beschreiten können und
beschreiten müssen um die Deutschen und
die Bürger Israels näher zueinander zu
bringen die Jugend den Austausch der
Jugend zu fördern die Zusammenarbeit der
Wissenschaft die Zusammenarbeit der
Wirtschaft
weiterzuentwickeln und zu fördern damit
wir dem deutsch-jüdischen Verhältnis
eine entsprechende neue zusätzliche
Dimension verleihen die uns vielleicht
kämpft an Antisemitismus auch in
Deutschland ein für allemal zu
überwinden herzlichen
Jürgen hart war das für die
Unionsfraktion und nun spricht die
kulturstaatsministerin Claudia Roth
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrter
Ron rosa
Charlotte Knobloch deren 90 Geburtstag
wir vor wenigen Tagen gefeiert haben hat
nie vergessen was sie am 9 November
1938 in München erleben musste sie hat
es nie vergessen können niemand könnte
das wer erlebt das in wenigen Tagen
alles was dem eigenen Leben Gewissheit
und Vertrauen gehabt zerstört wird der
wird das sein Leben lang nie vergessen
wer den 9 November
1938 erlebt hat für den kann nie wieder
niemals nur ein leeres Wort bleiben sagt
Charlotte Knobloch kein leeres Wort
nicht im Land der Täter nicht in dem
Land das Charlotte Knobloch das Fritz
Bauer und mit ihnen viele Jüdinnen und
Juden trotz der Show trotz der
unermesslichen Schuld dieses Land uns
mit aufgebaut haben
wir sind heute versammelt um zu bekennen
voll Scham zu bekennen jüdisches Leben
ist in Deutschland noch immer bedroht
Antisemitismus existiert noch immer in
diesem Land deswegen heißt erinnern an
den 9 November auch immer kämpfen für
die Demokratie und gegen Antisemitismus
und diese Erinnerung
diese Erinnerung ist keine Pflicht und
keine Bußübung keine ich zitiere
dämliche bewältigungspolitik wie Sie
Björn höcke für die AFD bezeichnet
diese Erinnerung ist ein Kampf auch
gegen die Feinde der Demokratie die
Erinnerung an den 9 November an den
Opfer des an die Opfer des Terrors an
das was diesem Tag vorausging und an die
Konsequenzen die dieser
Zivilisationsbruch hatte diese
Erinnerung ist ein Dienst an uns selber
an uns allen der 9 November sagt
Charlotte Knobloch war das Tor nach
Auschwitz es ist die Wahrheit und diese
Wahrheit sie ist uns zuzumuten sie
erinnert uns daran dass wir nicht
vergessen dürfen dass das Gift des
Hasses langsam wirkte und wirkt dass auf
Verleumdung Diskriminierung folgte auf
Ausgrenzung Verfolgung und am Ende
Zerstörung und Vernichtung stand Hass
Missgunst und Ausgrenzung bedeuten
Verrat an der Demokratie
über 3000 Fälle antisemitischer
Straftaten die das
Bundesinnenministerium im vergangenen
Jahr feststellte sind über 3000 zu viel
die Vielfalt die Vielzahl an
judenfeindlichen Straftaten und ja auch
der schlimme Vorfall bei der Dokumenta
sind nicht nur ein Angriff auf jüdisches
Leben in unserem Land sondern auch ein
Angriff auf unser Zusammenleben auf das
wir alle und sind auch eine riesengroße
deswegen eine riesengroße
Herausforderung für die Politik in
unserem Land
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen unser
Land hat am 9 November 1938 seine Würde
verloren es hat Jahre und Jahrzehnte
gedauert um wieder aufgenommen zu werden
in den Kreis der zivilisierten Länder
ganz zu allererst verdanken wir dies
Israel und unseren jüdischen Mitbürgern
und Mitbürgerinnen die Freundschaft mit
Israel die Zusammenarbeit und der Kampf
gegen
Antisemitismus sind unverrückbarer Teil
der deutschen staatsreson und sie sind
konstitutiv für unsere Demokratie und
für die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
und es war der Kampf gegen das Vergessen
der dieses Land der unsere Gesellschaft
verfasst hat ich glaube man kann sagen
so sind wir zu einer freien und
demokratischen Gesellschaft geworden und
wir sind nicht am Ende der Geschichte
angekommen unser Leben in Freiheit und
Demokratie ist keine
Selbstverständlichkeit wer sich erinnern
kann weiß das und wer daran erinnert
weiß das auch wir werden unsere Freiheit
und Demokratie verteidigen müssen sagt
Charlotte Knobloch recht hat sie
vielen Dank Frau Claudia Roth änderte
hier mit einem Zitat in der Debatte
Antisemitismus bekämpfen erinnern statt
Handeln angesichts des 84
jahrestags der Reichspogromnacht in
Deutschland Mark Jong der
kulturpolitische Sprecher der
afd-fraktion ist der nächste Redner
Präsident meine Damen und Herren am
heutigen 9 November dem deutschen
Schicksalstag im Guten wie im Bösen zur
Bekämpfung des Antisemitismus aufzurufen
ist angemessen und geboten erinnern
heißt handeln wie es im heutigen Titel
heißt das stimmt in diesem Kurzschluss
aber leider nicht die deutsche
Erinnerungskultur macht zunehmend den
Eindruck einer kompensatorischen
Veranstaltung viel symbolischer Aufwand
und pathetische Worte die immer öfter
aber nur kaschieren dass es einen
eklatanten Mangel an Handlungen gegen
den wachsenden Antisemitismus gibt
schlimmer noch während immer neue
Mahnmale und Gedenkorte zu den
NS-Verbrechen errichtet werden sorgt
Ihre aktuelle Politik zugleich dafür
dass sich Juden wieder unsicher und
bedroht fühlen in Deutschland dass sie
an Auswanderung denken müssen in
Frankreich ist es längst so weit das ist
doch die peinliche Wahrheit
sie sorgen dafür indem sie weiter die
Massenmigration aus einem Kulturkreis
fördern nämlich den islamischen in dem
nachweislich der größte judenhaus
weltweit grassiert die Umfragen und
Statistiken sind hier eindeutig fragen
sie bitte jüdische Mitbürger in welchen
Stadtvierteln in Berlin oder analog in
Paris oder anderswo in Europa sie am
allerwenigsten mit einer Kippa spazieren
gehen würden und sie werden eine
eindeutige Antwort erhalten es sind
nicht die Viertel mit der angeblich so
rassistischen Einheimischen
Mehrheitsbevölkerung natürlich gibt es
Antisemitismus überall aber hören Sie
endlich auf die Gesellschaft pauschal
anzubräunen und benennen sie Ross und
Reiter wenn sie von Antisemitismus
sprechen
und Frau Feser sie haben heute den
Islamismus benannt aber ihre generelle
Blindheit auf dem islamistischen Auge
kann unserem Land und speziell den Juden
in Deutschland noch teuer zu stehen
kommen wenn Sie hier nicht Umsteuern und
sie fördern ja auch ganz systematisch
den Antisemitismus auf der ideologischen
Ebene die Dokumente 15 hat mit ihren
Skandalen hat es ans Licht gebracht der
Postkolonialismus dem
kulturstaatsministerin Roth genauso
huldig wie ihre Vorgängerin im Amt
Monika Grütters CDU ist nicht nur eine
Ideologie des Ressentiments gegenüber
dem Westen und allen weißen es ist auch
eine Ideologie des ti der tief
verwurzelten Judenfeindschaft Edward
Said Gründervater des Postkolonialismus
bei istinensischer Herkunft hat sein
wissenschaftliches Werk explizit in den
Kontext seines politischen Engagements
gegen Israel gestellt ich zitiere hier
die FAZ vom September die Saat dieses
Hasses ist heute breit aufgegangen hat
den akademischen Diskurs zuerst
vergiftet und sie vergiftet jetzt
zunehmend auch unsere Kultur und
Erinnerungspolitik und solange sie eine
Ideologie idel und finanziell fördern
deren sumpfgewächs die Israel bei
gottbewegung BDs ist eine existenzielle
Bedrohung für Juden in aller Welt ist
ihr erinnern kein handeln sondern es tut
mir leid das sagen zu müssen zu einem
großen Teil Heuchelei und hören Sie
bitte auf Frau Roth mit ihren wirklich
haltlosen Anschuldigungen in unsere
Richtung wenn eine Politik für die Juden
für die Sicherheit der Juden in
Deutschland sorgen würde dann ist das
die Politik der AFD vielen Dank
vielen Dank nächste Rednerin ist die
Kollegin an Nico Glogowski Merten
ftpraxis
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen fertig Gäste
auf der Tribüne
es sind eigentlich so manche Worte an
diesem Pult die das Erinnern vergiften
dieser Satz sei mir gestattet jüdisches
Leben gehört zu Deutschland
das gilt für die Vergangenheit genauso
wie für die Zukunft die
novemberprogramme und das was daraus
folgte sind jedoch in unserer
kollektives Gedächtnis als grauenhafte
Verbrechen eingebrannt jüdisches Leben
sollte in Deutschland komplett
vernichtet werden
die Aufarbeitung der Vergangenheit ist
mitnichten eine Selbstverständlichkeit
Erinnerungskultur braucht Raum sie
braucht Orte innerhalb derer sie sich
entfalten kann sie braucht Mut und
Zuversicht
in meinem Heimatwahlkreis Braunschweig
hatte ich vor kurzem das Glück einen
dieser Orte das Braunschweiger
Landesmuseum hinter aegidien an welchen
wir die Erinnerungskultur für jüdisches
Leben in Deutschland pflegen
dokumentieren und archivieren zu
besuchen die Sammlung gehört die
Sammlung von Objekten des religiösen
Gebrauchs gehört zu den historisch
bedeutendsten in Deutschland sie ist ein
Zusammenspiel von Erinnerung von
Dokumentation und von Aufarbeitung
letzteres ist vor allem dann unabdingbar
wenn es um die Schaffung von
Perspektiven für die Gegenwart aber auch
für die Zukunft jüdischen Lebens geht
die historische Aufarbeitung der
Novemberpogrome und das Holocaust wird
stets auch die Fragen von Schuld und
Verantwortung auf die Auseinandersetzung
mit diesem Teil unserer Vergangenheit
ist und bleibt schmerzhaft aber auch
unabdingbar
die Frage nach der historischen
Verantwortung ist für jede Generation
die nach dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs
in Deutschland geboren wurde eine sich
immer wieder aufs Neue stellen der
Herausforderung
umso wichtiger ist es bewussten Raum für
die Präsenz jüdischen Lebens in
Deutschland zu schaffen
bis heute ist jüdisches Leben in
Deutschland bedroht der Hass auf
Jüdinnen und Juden nimmt vielerort zu
dies bestätigen leider auch die Zahlen
des Bundeskriminalamtes für
antisemitisch motivierte Straftaten
nur wenige Straßenzüge von hier steht
die Synagoge der jüdischen Gemeinde
Berlins unter anderem den Polizeischutz
und auch an der Braunschweiger
Braunschweiger Synagoge kann zum
heutigen Gedenken an die Reichsburg
Ohmacht die Kranzniederlegung wieder
nicht ohne Gegenwart eines
Streifenwagens stattfinden
ich wünsche mir sehr das jüdisches Leben
84 Jahre nach den furchtbaren Vorfällen
der Reichspogromnacht Raum im
öffentlichen Leben in Deutschland findet
ich wünsche mir dass die Präsenz
jüdischen lebenszonale maalität und zur
Pluralität unseres Alltags in der
Bundesrepublik gehört das ist möglich
ist ohne Angst und Hass
selbstverständlich jüdisches Leben und
privaten und öffentlichen Raum in
Kreuzstein zu praktizieren und zu leben
die bewusste Auseinandersetzung mit der
Vergangenheit das Pflegen von
Erinnerungskulturen wie sie zum Beispiel
durch das Landesmuseum Braunschweig aber
auch an vielen anderen Orten praktiziert
wird schafft so hoffe ich weiterhin die
Grundlage für die Entfaltung jüdischen
Lebens in Deutschland wir brauchen ein
sensiblen Umgang mit unserer
Erinnerungskultur im Inneren wie auch im
Ausland das verdeutlichte
das verdeutlicht da auch eine für diese
Woche geplante Veranstaltung des
Goethe-Instituts in Kooperation mit der
Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung in Tel Aviv
meine Kolleginnen hat es auch
angesprochen es ist unsere Pflicht als
Menschen nicht wegzusehen wenn jüdischem
Leben in Deutschland das Existenzrecht
abgesprochen wird es ist unsere Pflicht
Räume zu schaffen und zu bewahren in
denen die Erinnerung an jüdische Kultur
in Deutschland bewusst gepflegt
unterhalten wird wir brauchen auch für
zukünftige Generationen die noch vor dem
schwierigen Auseinandersetzungen mit den
Erinnerungen an die progrome und den
Holocaust stehen kollektive
Anknüpfungspunkte und Orte in Form von
Museen Synagogen vor allem aber auch
Menschen die das erinnert die Erinnerung
nicht vergessen
wir müssen Orte der Erinnerung schaffen
und erhalten denn handeln im Hier und
Jetzt das Einstehen für Präsenz
jüdischen Lebens im öffentlichen Raum
setzt Bewusstsein um das Geschehene
voraus und um die historische
Verantwortung die damit einhergeht denn
ganz im Sinne dieser Debatte meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren erinnern
heißt handeln das heißt
Erinnerungskultur bewussten pflegen es
heißt Raum für dieses Leben in
Deutschland zu schaffen das heißt
nachfragt wenn es unangenehm ist und es
heißt nicht wegsehen wenn seine Existenz
bedroht wird herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
Kollegin Lukowski Merten das auch nicht
wenn sie Zeit zu überschreiten aber
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin Simona
Kos SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine
9 November 1938 eine Mittwoch wie heute
brotteten sich um diese Uhrzeit die
horndera zusammen die nur wenige Stunden
später Synagogen anzündeten und
abbrennen ließen Geschäfte und Wohnungen
von Jüdinnen und Juden zerstörten und
Menschen misshandelten verhafteten auf
sie einschlugen und töteten nur ja nur
weil sie Juden waren und den
Nationalsozialisten als billiges
Feindbild als Sündenbock dienten die
Reichspogromnacht steht für eine der
schrecklichsten
antisemitischen Gewalttaten gerade weil
sie im Vorfeld wohlorganisiert dem
Volkszorn simulierte und anstachelte
es sollte in dieser Nacht deutlich
werden dass die Nazis mit ihren
Massenverhaftungen mit Sondergesetzen
und Demütigungen im Sinne der
Bevölkerung handelten die angeblich noch
härteres Vorgehen gegen Jüdinnen und
Juden verlangten
auf diese Nacht folgten in noch größerem
Umfang Vertreibung Verschleppung und
letztlich die Ermordung von 6 Millionen
Menschen in den vernichtungsladern nur
ja nur weil diese Menschen Juden waren
die Nationalsozialisten knüpften für ihr
schreckliches Handeln an tief geprägte
Vorurteile an
Judenhass und Juden Feindlichkeit waren
längst salonfähig
so wie der Antisemitismus des neunten
november 1938
keineswegs spontan war so hat er leider
keineswegs mit dem Jahr 1945 aufgehört
zu existieren ganz im Gegenteil er ist
da Tag für Tag
glücklicherweise wurden in den
vergangenen Jahren in den Bundesländern
Recherche und Informationsstellen zum
Antisemitismus eingerichtet die Ria
stellen wir gemeinsam meine Damen und
Herren sollten diese Stellen weiter
unterstützen und verstetigen nach den
Zahlen im Bericht von RIAS wurden im
letzten Jahr
2738 antisemitische Vorfälle verzeichnet
eine schrecklich hohe Zahl
leider müssen wir von einer noch höheren
Dunkelziffer ausgehen der RIAS
Jahresbericht liest sich bedrückend in
ihm ist die Rede von Bedrohung
massenzuschriften Hassmails
Sachbeschädigung Angriffen und von sechs
Fällen extremer Gewalt
nicht verzeichnet sind antisemitische
Schimpfwörter der Glaube an die
zionistische Weltverschwörung und
natürlich die Vorsicht und Angst von
Jüdinnen und Juden in unserem Land
sichtbar ihren Glauben zu leben und als
Jüdinnen und Juden erkannt zu werden
ich habe es auch bei uns in Brandenburg
erlebt und sehe es jeden Tag in den
sozialen Netzwerken im Zuge der
corona-proteste aber auch im
Zusammenhang mit dem ukrainekrieg werden
immer wieder
antisemitische Muster bemüht
und wir erleben es auch hier im
Bundestag immer wieder wie dieses Muster
von rechts befördert wird das was damit
geschieht meine Damen und Herren ist
geistige Brandstiftung
dem setzen wir demokratenen und
Demokraten folgendes entgegen der
härtefallfonds wird kommen sobald die
Bundesländer einer Beteiligung
zugestimmt haben noch in diesem Jahr
muss das Geld fließen es wird
allerhöchste Zeit für die Hochbetagten
jüdischen Kontingentflüchtlinge ich bin
sehr
ich bin sehr froh darüber dass die
Verhandlungen zwischen dem
Bundesfinanzministerium und der Jewish
clemens-konferenz erfolgreich verlaufen
sind und wir deutlich gemacht haben dass
wir mit der Bundesregierung der
Verpflichtung den Holocaust überlegenen
gegenüber Nachkommen es ist unsere
Pflicht den Holocaust Überlebenden in
der Ukraine zur Seite zu stehen ebenso
für den jüdischen Kindern aus
ukrainischen Waisenhäusern und allen
geflüchteten ich bin stolz auf diese
Bundesregierung die hier unkompliziert
hilft
meine
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir sollten alle eine Vorstellung davon
haben was Judentum in Deutschland
ausmacht jüdisches Leben gehört zu uns
ob in Neukölln in Frankfurt oder in
Bernau lassen sie uns wachsam sein
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam daran arbeiten
unserer historischen Verantwortung
gerecht zu werden lassen Sie uns noch
mehr offen und interessiert aneinander
sein und jüdisches Leben in Deutschland
in seiner Vielfalt mit Interesse und als
Bereicherung betrachten herzlichen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
der Appell von Simone Kos hier in der
Debatte wie man Antisemitismus bekämpft
Volker Ulrich spricht nun als nächstes
für die Unionsfraktion
herr Präsident meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
bereits im Jahr 2019 hat Rabbiner Henry
Brandt gewarnt Zitat der Antisemitismus
zeigt wieder seine Fratze
Hendrik Brandt wurde 1927 in München
geboren
im November 1938 ist der Messer seinen
Eltern nach Israel geflüchtet und konnte
so der Ermordung entkommen er diente als
Soldat in der israelischen Armee wurde
in London zum Rabbiner ausgebildet und
kehrte in das Land seiner Eltern in sein
Land zurück allein das ist eine Gnade er
wurde Vorsitzender der rabbinerkonferenz
bis zuletzt Rabbiner in meiner
Heimatstadt Augsburg und er ist im
Frühjahr diesen Jahres gestorben
er hat gesagt ich bin überzeugt dass das
Gespräch die Konfrontation mit
Unterschieden und Geschichte die beste
Waffe gegen Antisemitismus und Vorteile
ist
Geschichte
die November Pogrome des Jahres 38 haben
in den Abgrund der Shoa in die Ermordung
von Millionen und ihr menschlichung
verwiesen mit all der Verantwortung von
jenen die mitgemacht oder auch nur
weggeschaut haben
wir müssen aber auch die Zeit vor den 9
November 38 vor Augen haben wie konnte
es dazu kommen
die Antworten sind
es waren
antisemitische verschwörungserzählungen
im Umlauf
Vorteile und Verrohung in der Sprache
gesellschaftliche
Ausgrenzung und Stigmatisierung es ist
nicht wie damals aber die Mechanismen
funktionieren ähnlich deswegen müssen
wir stets wachsam sein unser
Anspruch muss sein
Juden müssen heute ohne Angst leben
können
überall aber ist das stets möglich
wenn Schulen und Kindertagesstätten und
Moscheen Synagogen polizeilich geschützt
werden müssen ist das möglich angesichts
von 3000 antisemitischen Straftaten
die meisten kommen aus dem
rechtsextremen Spektrum und dazu hätte
ich mir etwas gewünscht von dieser Seite
aber es war nicht absehbar das dazu
etwas kommt
es gibt auch
islamistischen und linksextremistischen
Antisemitismus gar keine Frage und er
beginnt nicht mit strafbaren Handlungen
das wäre eine unzuglässige Verengung
eine geradezu gefährliche Sichtweise wir
dürfen nicht schweigen über
Antisemitismus der sie doch
Verschwörungstheorien durch chatgruppen
frisst und droht die Mitte der
Gesellschaft zu vergiften vermeintliche
Kritik am Start Israel die nur aber als
Deckmantel für Antisemitismus steht auch
kulturelle Vorkommnisse wie dieses Jahr
bei der Dokumente
wir haben Verantwortung zu erinnern die
Verpflichtung besteht in der Aufklärung
aber auch in der Prävention kein Mensch
wird als Antisemit geboren
Menschen werden dazu
wie können wir verhindern dass Menschen
zu Antisemiten werden
das ist eine Frage von Bildungen
Aufklärung Hendrik Brandt hat gesagt von
gemeinsamer Arbeit und Gesprächen
ein versöhnter Ton was für eine Stärke
dieser Mannes
gerade weil Rabbiner Henry Brandt und
immer mehr Zeitzeugen nicht mehr unter
uns sind und sie fehlen liegt es an uns
die Erinnerung zu bewahren
nicht als Ritual
sondern als aufrichtige Mahnung
es gibt keinen Zeitablauf für die
Notwendigkeit des Gedenkens
die Erinnerung an die Opfer endet nie
erinnern
bleibt in diesem Land
jedem stets zumutbar
für ein nie wieder einzutreten
ist eine unerlässliche Pflicht mit dem
Aufruf am 9 November aber mit jedem Tag
unseres politischen Handelns vielen Dank
vielen Dank für die
damit kommen wir zur vorletzten Rednerin
in dieser Debatte das ist im Marlene
Schönberger sie ist in ihrer Fraktion
zuständig für die Bekämpfung von
Antisemitismus und setzt sich für die
Förderung jüdischen Lebens in
Deutschland ein demokratischen
Fraktionen von den 200.000 Jüdinnen und
Juden in Deutschland leben ca 70.000
jüdische Seniorinnen unter der
Armutsgrenze darunter viele shower
Überlebende ist ein krasses Versagen der
Politik wenn wir jetzt endlich einen
härtefallvorschaffen dann ist das ein
Anfang doch das kommt spät jüdische
Organisationen kritisieren seit
Jahrzehnten dass der Armut von Juden
Juden nicht begegnet wird und das ist
nur ein Beispiel für die Ignoranz die
jüdische Stimmen in diesem Land erfahren
für die Juden Juden haben Bedenken
Kritik zu äußern oder sogar
Selbstverständliches einzufordern weil
sie Angst haben dass die Politik sie im
Stich lässt
so auch wenn es um Antisemitismus geht
viel zu selten spielt das was Betroffene
berichten dabei eine Rolle mir ist
wichtig dass wir in der heutigen Debatte
ausgeht wir haben diesen Missstand
erkannt und wir wollen daran etwas
ändern
dafür müssen wir bei uns selbst anfangen
wir müssen uns fragen wie können wir der
Kritik und den Anliegen von Juden Juden
mehr Gehör verschaffen wie können wir
politische Räume zu safer spaces auch
für Juden Juden machen wie schaffen wir
es dass wirklich immer klare Kante gegen
Antisemitismus gilt auch dann wenn aus
dem eigenen politischen Lager kommt
eine Umfrage des American Judith Comedy
zeigt dass die Anhängerinnen
demokratischer Parteien keineswegs immun
gegen Antisemitismus sind und der Grünen
wähler:innen sind es 24 Prozent und
unter unionsanhänger:innen 32 Prozent
die der Meinung sind dass die Juden
ihren Status als Opfer der shower zu
ihrem Vorteil nutzen würden bei der SPD
FDP und der Linken sind es sogar noch
höhere Zustimmungswerte mit Abstand die
am höchsten sind sie beim Anhänger in
der AFD und Studien zeigen längst dass
der Antisemitismus zum programmatischen
Kern dieser radikale rechten Partei
gehört ihre Inszenierung als bojüdisch
das ist heuchlerisch und das ist
schädlich
liebe Kolleginnen eine oberflächlich
Anti antisemitische Haltung reicht nicht
aus wir brauchen mehr nämlich eine
dauerhafte Auseinandersetzung und eine
konsequente Positionierung an
Gedenktagen sagen wir ritualisiert nie
wieder und überall höre ich dass kein
Platz für Antisemitismus sei doch seien
wir ehrlich leider gehörte der
Antisemitismus immer zu Deutschland wenn
es bei der antisemitismusbekämpfung bei
Phrasen bleibt dann ist das ein Schlag
ins Gesicht der Betroffenen
dem Antisemitismus konsequent zu
begegnen liebe Kolleginnen das ist
mühsam dass es schmerzhaft das ist
frustrierend und es ist ein Kampf bei
dem wir Juden Juden viel zu lange
alleine gelassen haben wir müssen jeden
Tag daran arbeiten das zu ändern
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Schönberger
letzter Debatte ist der Kollege
Professor Lars castellucci
vielen Dank sehr geehrter Herr Präsident
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
liebe Gäste wir erinnern heute in dieser
Debatte an die Programme vor 84 Jahren
und uns beschäftigt die Frage wie es
dahin kommen konnte und
keiner von uns ist naiv und wir wissen
es gibt es böse es gibt es Verbrechen es
gibt die Radikalisierung manchmal sogar
von diesem Pult aus
aber die entscheidende Frage an der ich
immer am meisten festhänge ist wie
konnte das alles mitten unter uns
passieren
und das ist doch auch die zentrale Lehre
der Ereignisse vom 9 November 1938 das
eben zu viele zugeschaut haben es zu
viele haben passieren lassen oder aber
sogar manche der Gedanken und
Einstellungen geteilt haben die die
anderen zu den radikalen Taten getrieben
hat
und deswegen möchte ich auch heute sagen
wir haben bei dieser Debatte natürlich
über die Verbrechen die heute in unserem
Land oder in den letzten Jahren unserem
Land passiert sind gesprochen wir haben
den Skandal der Dokumenta besprochen
aber der andere groß ist Skandal den wir
in diesem Land haben das ist der der
jeden Tag in zu vielen Köpfen von
Menschen stattfindet dort wo die
antibiotischen Restaurants und
Stereotype auch heute noch festsitzen wo
20 Prozent der Menschen glauben Jüdinnen
und Juden hätten in diesem Land zu viel
Einfluss auf Wirtschaft und Finanzwesen
oder auf Politik und Medien und deswegen
kann ich nur appellieren der Kampf gegen
Antisemitismus ist kein Kampf alleine
gegen die Täter oder alleine ein Kampf
von zuständigen sondern es ist eine
Aufgabe der wir uns gemeinsam stellen
müssen weil sie in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft angesiedelt sein muss
und verzichten
verzichten können wir auf Bekenntnisse
zur Bekämpfung des Antisemitismus die
sich ihrerseits dieser Stelle Stereotype
bedienen und nur gegen andere Gruppen
richten denn Stereotype Vorurteile oder
sogar verfestigte Einstellung die sich
zu Menschenfeindlichkeit auswachsen die
haben eine gemeinsame Wurzel aus der
auch der Antisemitismus erwächst und dem
müssen wir uns entgegenstellen mit allem
was wir als DemokratInnen und Demokraten
aufzubieten haben
ich will abschließend auch als
religionspolitiker sagen die Religion
wird irgendwie kleiner und weniger an
unserem Land und die Menschen sollen
selber entscheiden wie sie es damit
halten aber wir brauchen auch zur
Bekämpfung des Antisemitismus eine
religiöse Alphabetisierung in diesem
Land die Menschen auch wenn sie mit
Religion für sich nichts am Hut haben
wollen und müssen und brauchen sollen
verstehen können was es mit Religion auf
sich hat und deswegen ist unsere
religionsverfassung die ein kooperatives
Verhältnis zwischen Kirche und Staat
Religion und Staat vorsieht und die auch
eine aktive Förderung von religiösen
Leben in diesem Land vorsieht eine gute
Verfassung und deswegen ist auch der
wichtigste Satz dieser Debatte am
Schluss wir sind froh und dankbar dass
jüdisches Leben in diesem Land wieder
seinen Platz hat und wir werden es
weiter fördern vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege damit
schließe ich die Debatte
und rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 6
sowie Zusatzpunkt 1 Beratung des Antrags
zur Fraktion der SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und FDP mit dem Titel
Protestbewegung im Iran unterstützen
Druck auf das regimeteran erhöhen sowie
ja also diese Debatte ist nun endet
beendet Bunde
Stag diesen in den nächsten top auf
Tagesordnungspunkt 6 da geht es eben um
die Unterstützung der Protestbewegung im
Iran denn seit dem seit sieben Wochen
halten die Proteste an nachdem eine
22-jährige
getötet wurde davon geht man auf China
Massa Amini wurde ursprünglich
festgenommen weil sie ihr Kopftuch nicht
richtig getragen haben soll so wie es
die Sittenpolizei gern hätte und wurde
festgenommen und ist dann
zusammengebrochen und starb drei Tage
später seitdem protestieren die Menschen
trotz möglicher
Strafen bis hin zur Todesstrafe
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Liebe zuschauende im Iran gibt
es keine freien Wahlen es gibt keine
Selbstbestimmung es gibt keine
Gleichheit vor dem Gesetz es gibt keine
Freiheit der Meinung immer wieder haben
Iranerinnen und Iraner auf Reformen
vertraut sie haben darauf vertraut dass
die Republik sich von innen heraus
verändern kann immer wieder sind sie
enttäuscht worden immer wieder ist ihre
Hoffnung auf Freiheit und
Selbstbestimmung niedergeschlagen worden
immer wieder haben die Menschen im
iranien Glauben verloren denn die
Islamische Republik ist keine Demokratie
am 20 September wurde Gina Master armini
eine iranische Kurdin in Gewahrsam von
Sicherheitsbehörden getötet ihr Tod war
kein tragischer Unfall sondern Mord
seitdem gehen jeden Tag Tausende und
Abertausende auf die Straße nicht etwa
weil sie einen Iran ohne Hijab wollen
sondern weil sie ein Iran wollen indem
man nicht zu jeder Zeit an jedem Ort
ohne einen einzigen gerechtfertigten
Grund von
Sittenpolizei revolutionsgarten oder
einfach nur staatlich bezahlten
Schlägertrupps verhaftet entführt
gefoltert oder getötet werden kann sie
wollen einen Iran ohne dieses Regime
meine Damen und Herren
sie rufen Tod dem Diktator der Mut und
die Tapferkeit dieser Menschen ist
grenzenlos denn anders als bei uns
arbeiten die Sicherheitsbehörden nicht
zu Ihrer Sicherheit sondern zur
Sicherung des Machtapparats mehrere
hundert Menschen wurden seit Beginn der
Proteste getötet das scheinparlament in
dem echte Reformer gar nicht zur Wahl
zugelassen sind hat mit einer 80 Prozent
Mehrheit entschieden dass 15.000
politische Gefangene hingerichtet werden
sollen die mullas fürchten den Ruf nach
Freiheit uns ist die Freiheitsbewegung
ein leuchtendes Beispiel
die Mehrheit dieses Parlaments
unterstreicht heute dass unsere
Solidarität kein Lippenbekenntnis ist
die Machthaber im Iran müssen wissen sie
haben keine Zukunft und wir werden Ihnen
das Leben so schwer machen wie wir es
können weitere Verantwortliche kommen
auf die Sanktionslisten wir wollen nicht
nur ihr Vermögen einfrieren sondern auch
solches das von ihnen stammt und sich
bei Dritten befindet wir werden Behörden
in die Lage versetzen sanktioniertes
Vermögen aufzuspüren wir werden Visa
sperren ausweiten und wir werden die
Sanktionen auch beim Handel verschärfen
damit geltendes Recht nicht umgangen
wird solange sie Menschenrechte mit
Füßen treten wird es keine normalen
Beziehungen geben für die demokratische
Zivilgesellschaft müssen wir tun was wir
können lassen sie uns Brücken zu
Kulturwissenschaft und NGOs aufrecht
erhalten wir müssen beim Aufbau eines
freien Internets unterstützen und wir
müssen iranische Stimmen vor
regimekräften in Deutschland konsequent
schützen wir diesen humanitäre Visa
vergeben und Asylverfahren für
Iranerinnen und Iraner erleichtern denn
das ist was Solidarität konkret bedeutet
meine Damen und Herren
den Menschen im Iran sagen wir haltet
durch die Zukunft des Irans ist eine die
ihr bestimmt wir stehen an eurer Seite
meine Großmütter werden die Befreiung
dieses großartigen Landes leider nicht
erleben aber meine Mutter meine Tanten
meine Cousinen deren Töchter und
Millionen von Frauen im Iran die der
ganzen Welt gerade beweisen dass
Frauenrechte dass Menschenrechte nicht
gegeben werden sondern von Geburt an
bestehen dann sind die ich danke Ihnen
für die Aufmerksamkeit
kW am Mann sorry hat hier natürlich noch
mal seine Familie erwähnt seine Eltern
sind aus dem Iran nach Deutschland
gekommen erst dann schon in Gießen
geboren hat aber natürlich
hier auch immer noch viele Verbindungen
Norbert Röttgen spricht jetzt für die
Unionsfraktion herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das was wir seit einigen Wochen im Iran
erleben das ist in der Dimension und in
der gesellschaftlichen breite natürlich
nicht in den Intentionen nur mit einem
historischen Ereignis vergleichbar
nämlich
dem Sturz des Schah im Jahre 1979 und
der Islam mit der folgenden islamischen
Revolution das ist keine Prognose wie es
ausgeht aber ich beschreibe das um die
Dimension des Geschehens zu
verdeutlichen es geht nicht mehr nur um
Proteste sie haben es auch gesagt Herr
Kollege sondern es ist eine
revolutionäre Bewegung im Iran im Gange
und daraus folgt dass für Deutschland
die Zeit gekommen ist dass wir uns
entscheiden es ist jetzt nicht mehr die
Zeit zu lavieren sondern Deutschland
muss Position und Partei beziehen in
dieser historischen Situation
schon in ihrem Titel greifen Sie diese
Dimension nicht auf sie sprechen von
Protesten aber es geht um revolutionäre
Bewegung die im Iran stattfindet die
richtige Antwort Deutschlands müsste
sein
maximalen Druck auf das Regime maximale
Unterstützung für die Protestierenden
das wäre die richtige deutsche
Außenpolitik
wir erleben
wir erleben das Gegenteil und auch in
diesem Antrag ist es wieder dokumentiert
man könnte fast glauben dieser Antrag
von den Fraktionen ist im Auswärtigen
Amt geschrieben worden weil der Antrag
auch den Geist atmet Deutschland macht
in dieser Situation
mini-sanktionen Deutschland macht nur
das was das obligatorische Mindestmaß an
Druck für das Regime ist und dadurch
fühlen sich die Protestierenden im Stich
gelassen meine Damen und Herren
Deutschland leistet zu wenig
[Applaus]
zumindest 90 die Grünen ja
Brugger stellt die Zwischenfrage ihre
Rede wie auch über ihre letzte Rede mehr
als irritiert und kann ihn auch nur
empfehlen mal ihren Antrag neben unseren
zu legen und was glauben Sie eigentlich
warum der deutsche Botschafter im Iran
dauernd eingestellt wird warum von
außenpolitischer Einmischung geredet
wird warum gerade unsere Außenministerin
baerbock dort zu Speerspitze des
Widerstands der Kritik und vor allem der
konkreten Maßnahmen gegen dieses Regimes
immer wieder mit aller Härte kritisiert
wird haben sie nicht mitbekommen das ist
bereits ein Sanktionspaket gab dass das
nächste ansteht dass die Listung
weiterer Person vorbereitet wird das ist
eine deutsche Initiative war ebenso die
Frage dass Menschenrechtsrat zu
thematisieren Maßnahmen zu
erkundenability auf den Weg zu bringen
zum Schutz der Zivilbevölkerung das
alles hat diese Bundesregierung
geleistet und natürlich wünschen wir uns
alle wir hätten ein Instrument diese
Gewalt zu beenden wer tut das nicht aber
hören ja hier auf zu behaupten dass
diese Bundesregierung nichts tut sondern
es ist Annalena baerbock die hier an der
sperrspitze des Widerstands steht
Frau Kollegah
ich glaube dass sowohl sie wie auch die
bundesaußenministerin
übereinstimmen dass keiner von uns sich
anmaßen sollte wie wir die wir hier in
Sicherheit sind stehen und debattieren
in einem freien Parlament dass wir an
der Spitze irgendeines Widerstandes
stehen an der Spitze des Widerstandes
stehen die Frauen und Männer im Iran die
für ihren Freiheitskampf gefoltert und
getötet werden also wir alle glaube ich
tun gut daran mit einem angemessenen Maß
an Demut und Bescheidenheit in dieser
batte teilzunehmen
aber ihr Punkt ist der ganz
entscheidende Punkt
dass der Botschafter sie wollen hier
darstellen dass die einbestellung des
Botschafters Ausdruck ist der
Entschiedenheit der Politik der
Sanktionspolitik und der
unterstützungspolitik Deutschlands das
ist glaube ich wenn das das Maß an
Reaktion ist dass sie herbeiführen
wollen dann ist es ein Beweis dafür dass
es einfach zu wenig ist es ist einfach
eine Realität
dass die bundesaußenministerin tagelang
nach dem Mord Angina massa-amini
geschwiegen hat es ist eine Realität
dass in Kanada 10.000 Angehörige der
Revolutionsgarden sanktioniert sind dass
die USA dabei sind die
Internet-Kommunikation
wiederherzustellen und Deutschland und
Europa rühmt sich dass elf Personen
sanktioniert worden sind und vier
Organisationen Herr Bundeskanzler sie
haben sich zu diesem Thema in zwei
Tweets bislang geäußert ich bin ganz
sicher und überzeugt dass wenn Sie sich
einmal in persönlicher Rede dieser
historischen Situation stellen würden es
würden die Protestierenden Frauen im
Iran es lohnen die Iraner in Deutschland
die iranischem in den deutschen es
wirklich begrüßen wenn sie als
Regierungschef Deutschlands sich hier zu
Wort melden würden
[Applaus]
ich gehe wieder zu meiner Rede es ist
eine Politik
des minimalen Drucks auf das Regime
die bundesaußenministerin hat am 30.10
in der ARD gesagt
und ich bleibe bei ihrem Thema Frau
Kollegin Burger obwohl die Zeit
natürlich wieder läuft sie haben gesagt
Frau baerbock es werde geprüft und ich
zitiere jetzt wie wie wir die
revolutionsgarten auch als
Terrororganisation Listen können das war
ihre Ankündigung am 30.10 vor neun Tagen
bislang ist nichts passiert und in
diesem Antrag steht nichts davon dass
die revolutionsgarten als
Terrororganisation gelistet werden soll
es ist nichts von ihrer Seite passiert
ich wäre sehr dankbar sie reden gleich
wenn Sie uns das Ergebnis nach neun
Tagen ihre Ankündigung vielleicht der
Prüfung einmal mitteilen könnten denn
jetzt sind nicht Prüfung gefragt sondern
Taten sind gefragt Handeln
Entscheidungen klare Signale alles das
ist gefragt
das Regime hat in der Zwischenzeit als
die Regierung anfing zögerlich zu
agieren ein bisschen was zu machen immer
weiter eskaliert sie haben es auch eben
beschrieben die ersten Hinrichtungen
sind erfolgt die Gewalt wird immer
brutaler Menschen werden gefoltert
14.000 Menschen sitzen in den
Gefängnissen das Parlament hat gerade
mit größter mehr mit großer Mehrheit
beschlossen und gefordert was praktisch
jeder protestierende hingerichtet wird
wenn diese Revolution scheitert dann
wird es Hinrichtungen in Massen geben
wie man sie selbst im Iran noch nicht
gekannt hat was ist dann eigentlich ihre
Politik was machen sie dann und um das
zu verhindern müssen sie doch jetzt
aktiv werden und nicht dann wenn es
passiert wieder ihr Bedauern äußern wir
müssen endlich handeln
in ihrem Antrag
gibt es auch eine Passage
der Transparenz
warum machen Sie diese Politik die wir
für grundfalt schalten das beschreiben
sie doch implizit
indem sie nämlich auf Seite 4 des
Antrages schreiben und ausführen
dass das Scheitern der Verhandlungen um
das nuklearabkommen eine immense und
unberechenbare Gefahr für die gesamte
Region wäre
die größte Gefahr ist das Regime für die
gesamte Region und das mal klarzustellen
dieses Terrorregime dass die gesamte
Region in Flammen sitzt aber ich stimme
dieser Aussage zu
ich stimme der Aussage zu dass wir alles
daran setzen dass das nuklearabkommen
wirksam wird und wir haben alles daran
gesetzt aber sie machen zwei
grundlegende Fehler zwei gewaltige
Fehler der erste Fehler ist in ihrem
Festklammern an das nuklearabkommen
Verschließen sie die Augen vor der
inzwischen eingetretenen Realität sie
schreiben das Regime war ich habe dieses
genaue Zitat leider nicht mehr wahr nur
zögern konstruktiv zurückhaltend
konstruktiv in diesen Verhandlungen nein
die Realität ist das Regime hat den
europäischen Vorschlag das letzte Wort
das Äußerste Angebot brüsk abgelehnt hat
dieses Angebot mit
unangenehmbaren Forderungen verbunden
und spielt in dieser Frage nur noch auf
Zeit um die atomwaffenfähigkeit in
dieser Zeit zu erreichen das ist die
Realität sie klammern sich an etwas was
der Iran schon lange aufgegeben hat
letzte Bemerkung
selbst wenn es eine Chance gäbe das
atomabkommen zu retten
wäre ihre Politik falsch
denn was erleben wir im Iran nicht
irgendein Protest wir erleben dass die
Menschen Aufstehen in der Breite der
Gesellschaft für ihre Würde für ihre
Freiheit und historische Veränderung im
Iran ist möglich und in dieser Situation
haben wir nicht das Recht andere
Prioritäten zu setzen wir haben die
Pflicht das zu unterstützen meine Damen
und Herren und die Bundesregierung ich
appelliere an Sie in dieser Situation
der Möglichkeit historischer Veränderung
positionieren Sie Deutschland auf der
richtigen Seite der Geschichte auf der
Seite von Würde und Freiheit für die die
Iranerinnen und Iraner kämpfen vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
hat die bundesaußenministerin Anna-Lena
bärbock hier ja schon sehr deutlich
angesprochen und kritisiert und wir
werden sehen ob sie jetzt darauf
eingehen wird sie hält hier nämlich als
nächstes ihre Rede
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Schülerinnen und Schüler Gina Maser
Amini ist 22 Jahre alt als sie getötet
wird
ist 17 als er die Schule schwänzt und
man Protesten in der iranischen Stadt
Mascha teilzunehmen bei seiner
Beerdigung fragt sein Vater welches
Verbrechen sein Sohn begangen haben soll
dafür dass sie 24 Schrotkugeln in den
Bauch gejagt wurden
Nika shakarani ist 16 als sie bei
Protesten in Teheran getötet wird
Mohammad rachshani und omed sarani aus
sistan und balucistan sind 12 und 13
Kinder
ist 62
Kurdin an ihrem Grab steht ihre Tochter
ihre Haare sind abrasiert ihr Blick
trinkt den Smart ihr Foto ging um die
Welt
getötet ihren Familien entrissen
Masa obdol Nika
sie sind sechs von geschätzt über 300
Menschen die getötet und ihren Familien
entrissen wurden weil sie für das
eingestanden sind was für uns
selbstverständlich ist das Recht frei
über ihr Leben zu entscheiden das Recht
in Würde zu leben
dafür gehen die Frauen und Männer in
Iran seit fast zwei Monaten auf die
Straße
wer 14.000 Menschen sind dabei verhaftet
verschleppt worden
und das Regime droht Protestierenden
auch mit der Todesstrafe
angesichts der Wucht angesichts dieser
Brutalität
reichen mahnende Worte nicht aus und ich
verstehe nicht wie man sich über Tweets
an dieser Stelle austauschen kann
ich glaube das ist Aufgabe von
verantwortungsvoller Politik ist
dass wir strategisch und ehrlich die
Herren von der CDU analysieren wie wir
diesen Menschen beistehen können nicht
indem wir hier aus einem sicheren Raum
Versprechung machen
sie haben kein Wort die Namen dieser
Menschen erwähnt und wissen Sie was nein
wissen Sie was ich habe mir sehr genau
überlegt ob ich auf ihre Rede eingehe
aber ihre Rede wird ja zum Glück wir
sind in einem freien Parlament weltweit
gehört deswegen möchte ich genau auf
Ihre Punkte eingehen
warum nehmen wir uns Zeit um
sanktionspakete zu verabschieden weil
wir zum Glück in einer Demokratie und in
einem Rechtsstaat leben in einer
gemeinsamen europäischen Union so leben
wie die Menschen in Iran das gerne tun
würden und wissen Sie was ich möchte
nicht dass eine einzige Person entlüftet
wird auf unseren Sanktionslisten so wie
das auch passiert ist bei Listung von
russischen Akteuren wir haben strenge
Regeln dafür sie fragen mich warum ich
auf die anderen Europäer eingehe warum
ich warte warum ich nicht wie die
Kanadier vorgehe weil alles rechtssicher
sein muss sie sind Jurist sie wissen
dass sie in Teilen andere Rechtssysteme
haben als die Amerikaner und die
Kanadier wenn ich möchte dass jede
Person
verantwortlich zur Rechenschaft gezogen
wird dann reicht es nicht in den ich
hier reflexhaft irgendwelche Zahlen in
den Raum stehe sondern ich möchte wenn
ich den mutigen Frauen und Männern im
Iran verspreche ich stehe an eurer Seite
dass ich rechtssicher gemeinsam mit den
Europäerinnen und Europäern an ihrer
Seite stehe sie haben sie haben hier
gefragt jetzt hören Sie auf die
Antworten auf ihre Fragen sie haben hier
gefragt was wir seit neun Tagen mit
Blick auf die terrorlistung getan haben
ich sage Ihnen was das auszusprechen das
war gewagt weil wir eben ein anderes
Recht Verständnis haben als die
terroristung die damals noch von Herrn
Trump passiert ist ich fand es wichtig
dass auszusprechen um deutlich zu machen
dass mein aus meinem politischen
Verständnis
dass terroristische Aktionen gegen die
eigene Bevölkerung sind sie sind Jurist
sie wissen aber wie die terroristung in
Europa ist da kann ich einfach die
deutsche Außenministerin sagen das ist
jetzt meine persönliche Auffassung
deswegen machen wir das in Europa so
sondern wir müssen uns die Rechtslage
anschauen können wir uns gerne gemeinsam
tun und da kommen viele andere Europäer
zu anderen Auffassung und wissen Sie was
es klingt jetzt vielleicht so aber das
bin ich mittlerweile gewöhnt
dass ich eine Frau rechtfertigen muss
sie sie haben sie haben gefragt sie
haben gefragt warum
Agnieszka broga gefragt hat warum der
Botschafter einbestellt wird meinen sie
ist es ein Zufall dass sich der
iranische Außenminister beim hohen
beauftragten Borell über die deutsche
Außenministerin beschwert ich möchte
hier einmal ganz und diplomatisch reden
wenn wir an der Seite der Frauen der
Männer im Iran stehen wollen dann ist
unsere Verantwortung so wie wir das auch
getan haben bei dem mutigen Menschen im
Belarus dass wir gemeinsam ganz ehrlich
sagen wo auch unsere Baustellen sind wo
unsere Maßnahmen sind weil wir eben
nicht von außen einfach so eingreifen
können es gibt Dinge die würden wir uns
gerne wünschen die sind aber in den
internationalen Beziehungen die sind in
Rechtssystemen nicht möglich und
deswegen möchte ich auch an diesem
heutigen Tag unterstreichen deswegen
möchte ich auch an diesem heutigen Tag
unter erst haben sie gesagt sie
kritisieren den Passus zum jcpoa und
dann haben sie gesagt aber irgendwie
kritisieren sie ihn doch nicht diese
Haltung kann man sich als
Bundesregierung nicht leisten und ich
möchte an diesem heutigen Tag deutlich
unterstreichen warum es für uns als
Bundesregierung so zentral ist dass
dieses Regime dass das Existenzrecht
Israels infrage stellt niemals zu einem
nuklearen Waffenarsenal kommt ich habe
mehrfach deutlich gemacht es gibt keine
Verhandlung das haben wir bei in Münster
bei G7 unterstrichen aber ich werde
niemals diesen Regime ein Blankoscheck
zu geben zu sagen jetzt akzeptieren wir
doch irgendwie dass ihr nuklear anreich
hat nein diese nukleare Anreicherung die
muss gestoppt werden mit Blick auf das
Existenzrecht Israels und auch zum
Schutz der Menschen in Iran
und ich kann ich kann niemanden
versprechen ich kann niemanden
versprechen ob das alles Wirkung zeigt
zur Realität gehört das wissen wir nicht
Politik ist kompliziert Außenpolitik
erst recht weil wir eben von außen in
dieser Situation den Menschen in Iran
beistehen ich weiß nicht ich glaube das
weiß niemand das wissen auch nie sie
nicht wie das Regime weiter vorgehen
wird was sich aber weiß ist wir lassen
nicht nach jeden Tag werden wir
versuchen weitere sanktionspakete auf
den Weg zu bringen ich telefoniere mir
gerade die fingerwunsch damit wir
Menschenrechtsrat endlich den
accountability-mechanismus aktivieren
können ob das gelingt können sie mich
dann wieder befragen ich weiß es nicht
shinyang ist im Menschenrechtsrat
gescheitert das zeigt aber wie wichtig
ist dass wir uns tagtäglich dahinter
klemmen weil alle die für Menschenrechte
arbeiten wissen wie wichtig es ist für
die Opfer dass die Täter unsere
Rechenschaft gestohlen werden und
deswegen stehen wir ich komme zum
Schluss an der starken an der Seite der
starken Frauen und Männer in Iran so
lange es notwendig ist wir tragen ihre
Stimme in die Welt sie heißen Masa sie
heißen Nika sie heißen abdulphasell sie
heißen Mohammad sie heißen Omid sie
heißen Minou mindestens 30 von ihnen
sind Kinder und sie sind stärker als das
Unrecht und die Gewalt herzlichen Dank
eine sichtlich bewegte
Außenministerin Anna-Lena baerbock ist
hier direkt auch auf die Kritik der
Union eingegangen hat auch noch mal
betont dass die Bundesregierung ein
eu-einheitliches Vorgehen in Bezug auf
den Iran anstrebt deswegen so wollen es
auch die koalitionsfraktion man etwa mit
ein
EU-weiten Sanktionen möchte man noch
einmal das Regime unter Druck setzen
Jürgen braun spricht jetzt für die
afd-fraktion Ministerin Anna Lena
baerbock nicht die Iraner leiden unter
dem mullerregime sondern die
bundesaußenministerin leidet im
Auswärtigen Amt und
entblättert hier ihr entsetzlichen
Zustand in Sachen Außenpolitik es ist
wirklich beschämend es ist beschämt was
hier abgeliefert haben in den letzten
Minuten so eine Rede unglaublich
jene Parteien die sich niemals kritisch
zum Kopftuch in Deutschland geäußert
haben inszenieren sich jetzt als
Unterstützer der Proteste im Iran
ausgerechnet jener Proteste die sich am
Kopftuch Zwang entzündet haben am
Kopftuchzwang
der den Ihnen einen Regime aufgezwungen
hat das von Anfang an von den
europäischen Linken hofiert und gestützt
worden ist die links-grünen Steinmeier
Joschka Fischer Claudia Roth und Co
haben uns jahrzehntelang weiß machen
wollen die sogenannten reforma sein ja
unsere Partner und ach so viel humaner
als Typen wie ahmadine Judd Glückwunsch
Telegramme zum Jahrestag der islamischen
Revolution und würdige atomabkommen und
sogar die rote Delegationsreisen im
Kopftuch waren die Folge am Sonntag hat
das iranische scheinparlament mit fast
80 prozentiger Mehrheit also auch mit
Unterstützung der angeblichen Reformer
beschlossen dass die Teilnahme an den
Demonstrationen fortan als Krieg gegen
aller gelten soll ein Tatbestand auf den
im Iran die Todesstrafe steht die Leben
von rund 14.000 Inhaftierten
Demonstranten befinden sich in Gefahr
allein weil sie von ihrem Recht auf
wohnungsfreiheit Gebrauch gemacht haben
seit dem gewaltsamen Tod der 22-jährigen
machte
armini sind den islamistischen
Schlägertrupps der Mullahs unzählige
weitere junge Frauen und Mädchen zum
Opfer gefallen und insgesamt geht es
mittlerweile um mehr als 300
Demonstranten Männer wie Frauen die vom
Regime in zwei Monaten ermordet worden
aber anders als wohl insgeheim im
hauswärtigen Amt erhofft reisen die
Proteste keineswegs ab nein die Proteste
gehen weiter und zwar keineswegs nur in
Teheran sondern ebenso in der Provinz
auch die dortige Bevölkerung hat seit
langem genug Formular Regime
die Islamische Republik ist ein Staat in
dem schwule vor die Wahl gestellt werden
entweder wegen Unzucht hingerichtet zu
werden oder sich sterilisieren und zu
Frauen umoperieren zu lassen und das
alles im Namen des Islam denn es gibt
eine Fatwa das aja toller kumeni die das
vorschreibt
das führt dazu dass der Iran nicht nur
im Verhältnis zur Bevölkerungszahl
sondern sogar ein absoluten Zahlen das
Land mit den meisten
Geschlechtsumwandlungen weltweit ist
vielleicht haben unsere
gender-gaga-fanatiker deshalb immer so
viel für die Mullahs übriger gehabt
ein solcher Staat darf hierzulande
Interessenvertretung haben ein solcher
Staat darf hier Handlanger Vereine
gründen die auch noch als gemeinnützig
anerkannt werden und deutsche
Steuergelder aus Staatsverträgen
bekommen wie im Fall der Blauen Moschee
im Rot-Grün Hamburg
jahrelang ist deutsches Zaudern
jahrelange Halbheiten haben nur der
islamischen revolutionsgrade genutzt sie
unterhält einen Schlägertrupp alwazit
der an der Niederschlagung der
Demonstration beteiligt ist aber die
Revolutionsgarde ist nicht nur kriminell
islamistisch sondern auch kriminell
kleptokratisch sie hat etliche Fabriken
und Raffinerien und sich unter den Nagel
gerissen die drohnenproduktionen nicht
zuletzt dass iranische Streben nach der
Atombombe erfolgen unter Aufsicht von
revolutionsgradlisten
wenn sie wirklich Druck auf das Regime
in Teheran ausüben wollen dann beenden
Sie Ihre heuchlerische Farce und
benennen Sie die Vorgänger als das was
sie sind brutaler islamistischer Terror
vielen Dank Herr Kollege braun
und in nächster Rednerin ist Renate alt
aus der FDP-Fraktion sie ist die
Vorsitzende des Ausschusses für
Menschenrechte und humanitäre Hilfe
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen werden die
Homepage des Auswärtigen Amtes aufruft
der liest dort ich zitiere vor Reisen
nach Iran wird gewarnt deutsche
Staatsangehörige werden aufgefordert
Iran zu verlassen für deutsche
Staatsangehörige besteht die konkrete
Gefahr willkürlich festgenommen verhört
und zu langen Haftstrafen verurteilt zu
werden Zitat Ende wir Deutsche können
dieser Gefahr entgehen indem wir dem
Iran einfach Fernbleiben aber über 80
Millionen Iranerinnen und Iranern können
und wollen ihre Heimat nicht einfach
verlassen die Proteste die wir im Iran
aktuell sehen sind keine einfachen
Proteste das was im Iran gerade passiert
ist eine Revolution es ist eine
frauenrevolution und wir werden bestimmt
noch viel über den Iran hören hier im
Deutschen Bundestag aber es ist ja auch
viel los in der Welt und anderen
krisenherren zum Beispiel in den USA und
das werden Ihnen jetzt die Kollegen von
der Tat genauer berichten
unterwegs in Großbritannien
abseits der ausgetretenen Pfade erkunden
wir die unberührte Natur
ein aufregendes
15.000 wurden verhaftet
zwei Drittel der Abgeordneten im
iranischen Parlament forderten harte
Urteile gegen die Protestierenden bis
hin zu Todesstrafe auf der Sänger Saman
Yasin wurde für die Teilnahme an
Protesten zum Tode verurteilt
Parlamentarier die die Todesstrafe für
Demonstranten fordern gehören für mich
auf die Sanktionsliste und zwar sofort
die ersten Sanktionen entgegen den Iran
wurden seitens der EU verhängt das
reicht aber nicht
Frau Bundesministerin
Deutschland muss beim Schutz der
Menschenrechte entschlossener handeln
die Entscheidungen Sanktionen zu
verhängen dauern zu lange und sind zu
zögerlich feministische
feministische Außenpolitik bedeutet für
mich das Angesicht der gravierenden
Menschenrechtsverletzungen und
Repressalien im Iran umgehend
weitreichende Sanktionen folgen die
Ampelkoalition legt heute einen Antrag
vor mit dem wir die Protestbewegung
unterstützen und den Druck auf das
Regime erhöhen wollen mir geht der
Antrag aber nicht weit genug es müssen
rasch weitere personenbezogene
Sanktionen gegen führende Vertreter des
Regimes und gegen die Revolutionswächter
folgen
die USA und Kanada machen es vor wie
schnell gehandelt werden kann beide
Länder haben wesentlich schneller
effektive Sanktionen gegen Personen und
Organisationen verhängt die an der
gewaltsamen Niederschlagung von
Protesten und an Tötungen beteiligt sind
warum wartet Deutschland immer ab bis
andere den ersten Schritt machen
Frau Bundesministerin das ist nicht die
neue Außenpolitik die sie angekündigt
haben und mit dieser iranischen
Regierung aktuell Verhandlungen über ein
atomabkommen führen zu wollen ist für
mich nicht nachvollziehbar
im Iran geht es gerade um das Ende des
molaregimes das wünschen sich die
mutigen Menschen im Iran wichtig ist
jetzt auch jene zu unterstützen die
Gewalt gegen Demonstranten dokumentieren
und Beweismaterial gegen die
Verantwortlichen für die Verbrechen
sammeln wir müssen außerdem mehr tun um
demokratische Oppositionelle und
besonders gefährdete Iranerinnen und
Iraner in Deutschland vor dem iranischen
Geheimdienst zu schützen auch die Rolle
der iranischen Botschaft bei der
Drangsalierung von Regimekritikern muss
untersucht werden für uns Freie
Demokraten steht fest Länder die
Menschen töten weil sie für ihre
Freiheit einstehen dürfen nicht mitsamt
Handschuhen angefasst werden
wir dürfen nicht zulassen
wir dürfen nicht zulassen dass diese
Proteste blutig niedergeschlagen werden
tun wir jetzt alles dafür dass ein
politischer Wandel und die lang ersehnte
Freiheit für alle in Iran endlich
Wirklichkeit wird
vielen Dank Frau
als Richter hält das Wort Liebe dr
Gregor Gysi Fraktion DIE LINKE
[Applaus]
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen alle Ideologien und Religionen
versuchen die Menschen zu
individualisieren immer wieder geht es
darum dass die Menschen sich nach
einschränkenden Moralvorstellungen und
Verhaltensweisen zu bewegen haben
eigentlich müsste der Grundsatz gelten
jede und jeder darf sein wie sie oder er
will es gibt nur eine Grenze wenn
dadurch Rechte anderer verletzt werden
dass dies nicht so ist führte in der
Menschheitsgeschichte zu schweren
Auseinandersetzungen einschließlich
Religionskriegen die evangelische Kirche
hat sich in der Reformation von der
katholischen getrennt sich
demokratischer strukturiert und Schritt
für Schritt Chancengleichheit für Frauen
hergestellt sie dürfen Pastorinnen und
beschwörden werden natürlich hat sich
auch die katholische Kirche entwickelt
aber nach wie vor werden Frauen im
Pastoren Bischofs Kardinals und Papstamt
ausgeschlossen eine Gleichstellung der
Frauen fehlt auch im Judentum wenn ich
daran denke wie der Aufenthalt in
Synagogen für Frauen und Männer geregelt
ist und im Islam fehlt die
Gleichstellung erst recht ganz schlimm
wird es aber erst dann wenn eine
Religion zur Machtmissbrauch genutzt
wird und genau das erleben wir mit dem
islamischen Staat mit anderen bestimmten
Sekten und seinen seit geraumer Zeit
gerade auch im Iran bestimmt im Männer
missbrauchen Religion um eigene
Herrschaftsverhältnisse zu sichern wie
kommen diese Kerle eigentlich dazu den
Frauen vorzuschreiben wie sie sich zu
kleiden haben noch nie haben die Frauen
den Männern die es vorgeschrieben und
nun wird gerade im Iran eine Frau in
Haft wegen angeblich falscher Kleidung
getötet wieso verletzt die Führung des
Iran das Menschenrecht von
Gleichstellung auf Frau und Mann eine
Mehrheit im iranischen Parlament will
gegen alle profitierten dem Protest
Inhaftierten Protestierenden
Todesurteilen
14.000 sind inhaftiert
ungeheuerlich selbst Kinder werden bei
den Protesten getötet schon in den 80er
Jahren mussten wir erleben dass im Iran
tausende DemokratInnen und Demokraten
hingerichtet wurden der Mut der jetzt
Protestierenden im Iran ist
bewundernswert
wann und wenn ich jetzt ist es Zeit für
eine feministische Außenpolitik die
solidarisch mit dem Protestierenden ist
doch was macht die deutsche Botschaft im
Iran sie versagt
Touristenvisum aus der Furcht dass die
Iranerin ein Asylantrag in Deutschland
stellen könnte in Bayern wo die CSU
regiert wurde ein iranischer
Asylbewerber und da falschem Vorwand in
die Passauer Ausländerbehörde bestellt
und festgenommen weil man ihn noch am 5
Oktober abschieben wollte drei Wochen
nach dem Beginn der Proteste zum Glück
hat die öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit dies
verhindert das Mindeste ist dass wir
Iranerinnen und Iraner die vor dem
Regime geflohen sind oder jetzt fliehen
umfassenden Schutz gewähren die
Gewalttaten des Regimes müssen unter
un-hoheit untersucht werden die Täter
dürfen sich in Deutschland nicht mehr
sicher fühlen und Sie müssen generell
zur Verantwortung gezogen werden
und wir müssen unsere politischen und
wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen nutzen
damit ihm Iran das Verhältnis zur Gewalt
und zu den Frauenrechten grundsätzlich
verändert wird hoffentlich erleben wir
tatsächlich eine Revolution
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
Gisi
als nächster Redner das Wort die
Kollegin der hier Türk Nachbauer
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und andere
für all die mutigen Frauen und Männer im
Iran die durch ihren Protest ihr Leben
riskieren gibt es kein Zurück mehr
so paradox ist auch klingen mag die
geeinte Kraft auf der Straße ist für sie
der Garant fürs Überleben und überwinden
eines mordenden molaregimes sie können
und dürfen jetzt nicht aufhören denn der
Mut und der Wille dieser Frauen und
Männer ist stärker als der staatlich
verordnete Terror gegen sie und genau
deshalb Herr Röttgen wird diese
Revolution nicht scheitern
ist es heute etwas ganz Besonderes am 9
November über die Kraft der Straße zu
sprechen an dem Tag an dem vor 33 Jahren
mit ins Protesten das Ende eines
unrechtsstaats eingeläutet wurde und das
Ende der Teilung Deutschlands endlich
Wahrheit wurde
viel wurde in den letzten Wochen über
die Protestbewegung im Iran gesprochen
alle demokratischen Parteien haben sich
mit den mutigen Frauen und Männern
solidarisiert wir sind auf Demos
gegangen haben das brutale Vorgehen
gegen demonstrieren aufs Schärfste
verurteilt und haben uns solidarisch in
den sozialen Netzwerken geäußert das war
und bleibt wichtig das reicht aber nicht
aus wir sind dem Kampf um Freiheit etwas
mehr schuldig die Waffen der
Protestierenden sind ihre Füße die sie
auf die Straßen tragen die Haare die sie
offen im Wind wehen lassen die Worte die
sie in Tweets und dann in Songtexte
verpacken die Bilder des Unrechts die
sie auf Leinwänden zu Kunstwerken
verarbeiten bekämpft werden sie mit
Schlagstöcken Schrotflinten scharfer
Munition Peitschenhieben und sexueller
Gewalt es geht um Terror es geht um
Folter es geht darum über die Leichen
des eigenen Volkes zu gehen um an der
Macht zu bleiben wir haben es mehrfach
gehört über 14.000 inhaftierte über 300
Tote davon 45 Kinder das sind die Zahlen
die gestern kursierten von der
dunkelzifffahrt von den Tausenden von
Verletzten die in Krankenhäusern nicht
behandelt werden dürfen werden wir noch
ausführlich sprechen müssen
all das macht ein Staat der als Mitglied
der Vereinten Nationen die Allgemeine
Erklärung der Menschenrechte anerkennt
und den Internationalen Pakt über
bürgerliche und politische Rechte
ratifiziert die iranische Verfassung
enthält sogar ein umfassenden
Grundrechtskatalog dass das aber nicht
mehr als nur Lippenbekenntnisse sind
wissen wir nicht erst seit dem 16
September seit dem Tag an dem Gina Mafia
armini auf brutalste Weise zu Tode kam
weil sie ihr Kopftuch nicht so tr die
Sittenpolizei gerne gehabt hätte wir
haben vielleicht zu lange weggeschaut
auch wir haben zugelassen das
jahrzehntelang Folter und Missbrauch
Willkür und Korruption dieses Land
geprägt haben es ist Zeit dass wir uns
eindeutig positionieren für die
Menschenrechte für Freiheit für
Chancengleichheit Rechtsstaatlichkeit
und für eine würdevolle Behandlung aller
sich positionieren heißt in diesem Fall
auch konkret zu sanktionieren deshalb
ist jeder dieser einzelnen 25 Punkte aus
dem Forderungskatalog dieses gemeinsamen
Antrags so richtig und genauso wichtig
es ist gut dass wir unsere Sanktionen
ausweiten und es ist gut dass wir den
Druck erhöhen wenn es nach mir
persönlich ginge und wenn es rechtlich
möglich wäre würde ich sogar gegen die
227 Abgeordneten die ihre Bereitschaft
gezeigt haben 14.000 inhaftierte
hinzurichten ich würde die auf diese
abge ausweiten
Krieg gegen Gott das ist kein Krieg
gegen Gott Liebe Mullahs und bei ihren
würden zu bleiben wenn es ein Krieg ist
das ist dann ein Krieg gegen die
Unterdrückung gegen Menschenverachtung
und für die Freiheit und
Selbstbestimmung und dieser Krieg wird
ohne Waffen geführt und wir Demokraten
und Demokraten in diesem Parlament
stehen an der Seite dieser
Demonstrierenden Yin yiyan Azadi danke
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine Damen
und Herren seit 50 Tagen kämpfen die
Demonstranten im Iran für Freiheit und
Selbstbestimmung seit 50 Tagen
protestieren sie gegen alltägliche
Gewalt und Gängelung der Mullahs seit 50
Tagen sind sie Verschleppung Folterung
Vergewaltigung und Mord ausgesetzt es
ist jeden Tag aufs Neue schockierend die
Berichte zu hören die Bilder und Videos
zu sehen wie dieses verbrechergeschim
mit denen umgeht die für ihre Freiheit
einstehen ich spreche sicherlich für die
meisten hier wenn ich sage dass wir mit
Demut Respekt und Bewunderung auf den
Mut der Protestierenden im Iran blicken
meine Damen und Herren
seit 50 Tagen warten die Iranerinnen und
Iraner auf den Straßen aber auch auf
Unterstützung und ich glaube man kann
Signale und Symbole senden angemessen
und rechtzeitig und im Hintergrund
trotzdem parallel rechtliche Fragen
prüfen und klären sorgfältige Arbeit im
Hintergrund kann doch keine
Rechtfertigung sein für eine Haltung der
Bundesregierung die wieder vielen zu
zögerlich und zu leise erscheint
und dabei geht es doch nicht um einen
Tweet es geht um Botschaften und um
Zeitpunkte und Frau Bundesministerin wir
respektieren in ihre Arbeit wir ziehen
ja oft auch SEO grüne an einem Strang
aber diese Kritik ist legitim und sie
ist notwendig
denn wir müssen darauf hinweisen dass
zwischen Überschriften wie
feministischer Außenpolitik und
tatsächlichen Taten eine Lücke ist und
das enttäuscht uns als konstruktive
Opposition im politischen Wettbewerb
aber vor allem enttäuscht es die mutigen
Menschen auf den Straßen im Iran und wir
denken uns das ja nicht aus das ist die
Rückmeldung aus dem Iran das ist die
Rückmeldung der Exil Iraner das ist die
Rückmeldung aus USA aus Kanada und vor
allem ist es auch offensichtlich die
Ansicht vieler Kolleginnen und Kollegen
in ihrer eigenen Koalition
und wenn Dinge komplex sind dann lassen
Sie uns doch die einfachen Dinge machen
und das auch konkret
beschreiben im Antrag steht zum Beispiel
drin man müsste Prüfen des islamische
Zentrum in Hamburg zu schließen das wird
doch seit Jahren von Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet die Lage ist doch klar da
muss ich nichts prüfen da muss die
Bundesregierung sich für eine Schließung
einsetzen oder für eine Schließung
hinwirken das kann man doch ganz klar in
diesem Antrag formulieren und so hat
das auch eine Signalwirkung an denen die
hier in unserem Lande Hass und Hetze
betreiben denn diesen verbrecherischen
Regime den müssen wir auf allen Seiten
klare Kante zeigen und deshalb fordere
ich sowohl von einem Antrag denn dieses
Parlament hier beschließt als auch vom
Handeln der Bundesregierung echte Taten
herzlichen Dank vielen Dank
diese Debatte ist der Kollege Dr Nils
Schmidt SPD-Fraktion
herr Präsident meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
es ist bedauerlich dass die große
Einigkeit die in der Sache besteht jetzt
nicht dazu geführt hat dass wir diese
Debatte auch mit großer Geschlossenheit
entlang des Antrags der
koalitionsfraktion geführt haben denn
es stört mich schon liebe
cdu/csu-fraktion das feministische
Außenpolitik dann hier am redepult
vorkommt wenn es ein parteitaktisch
reinpasst aber sonst hört man von ihnen
weil feministischer Außenpolitik kein
Nutzer
und
man kann man kann über
antragsüberschriften sich streiten aber
dass diese Antrag klar benennt dass es
eben nicht eine der üblichen
Protestbewegungen ist sondern ein alle
gesellschaftlichen Schichten
ergreifender Prozess der Umgestaltung
und der Ablehnung des Regimes im Kern
das ist doch klar ausgesprochen und ich
finde es auch bedauerlich dass sie bei
der Sanktionspolitik nicht anerkennen
wollen dass es eben nicht reicht große
Reden zu schwingen sondern dass wir sehr
konkret Rechtssicherheit für diese
Sanktion brauchen und das letzte Wort
ist ja noch mal gar nicht gesagt es geht
ja weiter und die Außenministerin hat
unsere volle Unterstützung weitere
konkrete sanktionspakete mit Listungen
vorzubereiten durchzusetzen zum Beispiel
auch gegenüber den Parlamentarier und
Parlamentariern im iranischen Parlament
die jetzt die Todesstrafe durchsetzen
wollen so wie wir die russischen
Parlamentarier sanktioniert haben die
die Annexion der der Grimm und die die
den erob Krieg in der Ukraine
unterstützen das spricht doch überhaupt
nichts dagegen und wir werden das mit
großer Entschiedenheit und
Geschlossenheit vorantreiben und deshalb
hätte ich mir gewünscht dass wir da mehr
Geschlossenheit zeigen um auch ein
eindeutiges Signal in die iranische
Gesellschaft hineinzusehen
und ich bin ausdrücklich dankbar dass
wir uns einig sind beim nuklearabkommen
denn
das iranische mularegime ist furchtbar
und schlimm aber eine unerregie mit
Atombomben wären noch schlimmer und noch
furchtbarer für die Iranerinnen und
Iraner für die Region deshalb ist es gut
dass wir die Bemühungen um den Atomuhr
Atom und bombenfreies Iran weiter
unterstützen denn wir sehen am Beispiel
Nordkorea wo das endet wenn diese
Bemühungen scheitern die völlige
Unantastbarkeit eines Regimes mit der
Atombombe kann nicht unser Ziel sein und
ich will ein letztes sagen oder will ich
uns alle einladen dazu ja es gab auch
Fehleinschätzungen was die innere
Entwicklung des Irans anbelangt wir
haben vielleicht zu lange dran geglaubt
dass Reformkräfte tatsächlich sich
durchsetzen können vielleicht haben wir
auch zu große Hoffnungen in den
Abschluss des atomabkommensgesetz was
die Effekte außerhalb der
atomwaffenfrage Stichwort Öffnung des
Irans anbelangt
die innere Verhärtung des Irans stammt
ja nicht von vorgestern sondern ist ein
langwieriger Prozess deshalb sind auch
liberalisierungsspielräume die wir
versucht haben anzustoßen durch dieses
Abkommen vielleicht gar nicht so groß
gewesen schon bei Abschluss des Abkommen
wie wir sie damals eingesetzt haben ich
glaube diese Selbstkritik was die
Einschätzung eines autoritären bis
totalitären Regimes anbelangt die steht
uns auch gut an wenn wir heute in den
Iran schauen in diesem Sinne bitte ich
um Unterstützung für diesen Antrag der
koalitionsfraktion
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen einen schönen
guten Abend von meiner Seite auch an die
BesucherInnen Besucher auf den
Zuschauertribünen und ich schließe damit
die Aussprache für den
tagungsordnungspunkt 6 und wir kommen
auch zur Abstimmung über den Antrag der
koalitionsfraktion auf Drucksache 43 29
mit dem Titel Protestbewegung im Iran
unterstützen Druck auf das Regime in
Teheran erhöhen wer stimmt für diesen
Antrag
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen wer
stimmt dagegen CDU CSU wer enthält sich
AFD und die Linke der Antrag ist damit
abgenommen angenommen wir kommen zum
Zusatzpunkt Nummer eins der Abstimmung
über den Antrag der Fraktion Die Linke
auf der Drucksache 43 39 mit dem Titel
Frau